. Thank you. Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, was ist das? Dankeschön. Dankeschön. Irgendwie, ich hätte das ja immer über Echtens erwartet. Ja, ehrlich gesagt, man ist halt noch ein bisschen enttäuscht. Ja, schon so ein bisschen. Wir haben das in der Probe so oft durchgespielt und wir haben immer gesagt, setzt euch hin, setzt euch hin, aber das ist ganz schön. Und der Probe stand auch alle jeweils und leider stand hier rum und rum, so Lichtleute sind hier rumgelaufen, man war ja gewohnt, dass Leute stehen hier rum. Naja, wie geht's euch heute, geht's ja gut? Sehr schön. Ey, wir müssen ja mal sagen, was für eine Folge ist es eigentlich. Es ist die Folge, aber das weiß ich gar nicht, die Folge 1870, die wird ja erst 2019 veröffentlicht, deswegen ist die Folge 1828. Erstmal, das ist wie bei Rotem Wein, die Folgen müssen erst mal ein paar Wochen im Giftschrank und dann werden sie richtig... Dann werden sie vergessen. Wir haben ja schon geguckt, das ist ungefähr der Punkt, ab da muss man einen Anlauf nehmen, um Stage-Diving zu machen. Das heisst, falls ihr Stefan Tietze nervös in Richtung hinteren Bereich des Tribüne gehen solltet. Vor ein paar Wochen war ich in der Heimat und da kam es zu dem Moment eines Stage-ibings, wo man dachte, das ist nicht die richtige Location, es waren 20 Leute im Publikum. Aber die Stimmung ist hochgekocht, es geht ja schnell in so kleinen Locations, also passt auch heute Abend. Und es ist da wirklich so, dass der Typ plötzlich meinte, auf das Publikum springen zu müssen. Und ich war der Einzige, vielleicht weil ich nüchtern war, aber der Einzige dachte, das ist eine richtig beschissene Idee gerade, das kannst du nicht machen. Du bist ja auch der Grösste, du trägst ja auch Mitverantwortung, weil du ja der erste Kämpfer bist. Ja, natürlich, ich hättest ankommen. Das ist wie wenn man etwas in der Treppe hochträgt und unten steht. Ich trage alles und der oben, der muss eigentlich gar nicht mehr halten. Das, nee, da darf ich dir nicht folgen, nein, oben ist der beschissenere Platz beim Treppehochtragen. Weil du rückwärts gehen musst. Ja, vor allem weil du hast den ganzen Scheiss zwischen den Ballen, du kannst ihn nicht richtig aufstellen. Oben ist schlechter. Und deswegen finde ich es gut, dass wir hier ein Publikum haben. Wer ist der Meinung, dass oben vor allem beschissenere sind? Ah geil! Das Volk hat Recht. Ey, das haben wir, das fehlt wirklich. Es hat niemand geklatscht, da hat er ein Platz. Du hast mich hier im Platz gerecht. Als wäre es dafür, dass der, der unten trägt, im Bett, was hochgetragen werden muss, die meiste Kraft aufwenden muss. Es geht nicht um Kraft, wir sprachen von Kraft. Stopp, aus jetzt! Wir sprachen nicht um Kraft, wir sprachen von unangenehm. Merkt ihr das? Das ist reversed-engineered, wir drehen noch mal das ganze Argument im Video um, das ist deine Taktik, aber dafür liebe ich dich. Aber die Versuchung ist immer sehr gross, wenn man so ein Publikum zur Verfügung hat, einfach konstant Applaus einzufordern, weil sich das gut anfühlt. Aber die tragen einfach alle Podcasts auf den Schwersten und man kann sich nicht so richtig ernst nehmen, weil man weiß, was sie in ihrer Freizeit machen und was sie eben genau nicht machen. Aber es ist ja einfach, man kann mal sagen, ein Applaus für Stefan Dietze, meine Damen und Herren! Wow! Einen Applaus für Shrek 2, meine Damen und Herren! Das ist ein guter Film! Ja, mehr Applaus. Einen Applaus für Shrek 1, meine Damen und Herren! Niemand gewinnt gegen Shrek 1. Ich muss sagen nochmal, an der Stelle Respekt an Hitler, dass der Wir sind fünf Minuten und vier Minuten! Lass mich zu Ende reden, dass der sein Ding durchgezogen hat, ohne konstant einfach, weil muss man ja auch mal sagen, das was wir kennen aus dem Geschichtsunterricht ist ja so ein Best-of so, der hat ja auch viel Ja, der hat viel Quatsch gemacht, viel Albumsachen, auch viel B-Seiten auch produziert, ja, auch viel von den Touren und so, das weiss man ja nicht, und der war auch viel langweiliges Zeug, wo sich dachte, einfach mal nochmal so, jetzt schmeisse ich nochmal so einen kleinen Spruch rein, einfach um Applaus zu kriegen. Hat er nicht gemacht. Das muss in dem Wochenende. Hat er nicht gemacht? Einen Applaus für Adolf Vittermeier, meine Damen und Herren. Und ich würde sagen, die Leute waren ihm wohlgesonnen, das kann man schon sagen. Ja, das stimmt. Also er hat einen einfachen Applaus bekommen. Er hat ein sehr einfaches Publikum. Ich finde es hat ein bisschen was von einer Sekte, finde ich alle. Alle gucken in die gleiche Richtung, alle hören uns irgendwie zu. Irgendwie unser Emblem ist im Hintergrund. Ja. Wer ist bereit, heute Abend noch Gift zu trinken? Hände hoch, Hände hoch, eins, zwei, fehlen erst drei. Sehr schön. Ihr merkt es vielleicht, ihr habt es vielleicht gemerkt, als ihr reinkommen seid, es fehlt ein bisschen was. Es fehlt was, oder? Spürt ihr das irgendwie, es fehlt, irgendwas fehlt, irgendwas ist gerade nicht da.
Weisst du, was ich meine, Stefan?
Ja, ja, ja, eigentlich müssen wir auch noch mal anfangen komplett, weil Johanna fehlt.
Johanna fehlt. Ihr habt es vielleicht mitbekommen, als ihr reingekommen seid, Johanna ist nicht da.
Als sie draußen in der Schlange stand, also es hat Johanna gefehlt.
Johanna ist stark abgegangen.
Johanna hat uns geschrieben vor der Sendung, dass sie leider zu spät kommt, dass sie leider zu spät kommt. Da habe ich mich auch gefragt, so wenn du schreibst du Sting vorher, so sorry, vor allem auch nicht irgendwie, sie meinte sie, könnte ich vielleicht dem Typen beim Einlass sagen, dass ich ein bisschen später komme, aber er schreibt dem Typen,, er schreibt den Veranstalter oder sowas. Ich würde das Johanna zurauhen, so, sehr geehrter Herr ACDC, leider muss ich Ihnen mitteilen, dass Sie zum Konzert am 7.8. deswegen, Johanna kommt ein bisschen später. Ich meine, der Rest der Klasse hat es auch geschafft, rechtzeitig zu kommen, ich weiß nicht, warum Johanna nicht. Es kommen die Lehrersprüche. Wir haben natürlich, und wir tragen Johanna im Herzen, denn wir alle kennen, wir alle sind auch schon mal zu spät gekommen und wir wissen, wir haben viel um die Ohren, wir haben viel zu tun. Deswegen haben wir Johanna natürlich heute als Geschenk des Abends einen extra Platz in der ersten Reihe verschafft, den sie extra für sich heute hier reserviert hat. Auch weil es ein bisschen unangenehm ist, muss man sagen, die ganze Reihe hier durchzulaufen, an allen vorbei und ich würde sagen, was sie nicht weiss, dass wir wissen, dass sie Geburtstag hat heute.
Richtig, Johanna hat heute Geburtstag. Und wenn sie reinkommt gleich, sich so durchdringt, sorry, sorry, sorry, und dann so auf Zehenspitzen hierherläuft, dann alle singen bitte, das wäre ganz gut.
Ja, das wäre gut, das wäre schön, einfach weil Johanna einfach, die hat ein hartes Leben, die hat eine schwere Zeit gerade und deswegen möchten wir Ihnen einen schönen Tag heute führen. Stefan greift zuerst eine Flasche. Ohne Scheisse, ich weiß auch nicht, zu früh, ne? Zu früh? Zu früh, zu früh. Strahlt Unsicherheit aus. Ein paar Leute haben schon angemerkt, dass die Flaschenverteilung ein bisschen ungleichmässig ist. Ich habe zwei Flaschen... Mein Vorschlag war fünf und ich habe richtig viel Lacher bekommen, aber so... Das machen wir nicht nach dem Motto. Wo man schon merkt, okay, ich habe aber auch keine Referenzzahl gehabt, also manche haben eins, aber das war mir jetzt echt zu wenig eigentlich. Und du hast was mit zwei, okay. Ihr seht das ja nicht, weil ihr uns ja sonst nur hört, aber nicht seht, aber Stefan haut immer wirklich zwei riesige Fässer Wasser währenddessen weg. Einfach wahnsinnig viel. Tatsächlich haben wir uns überlegt, gibt es Leute, die heute das erste Mal Stefan Tietze sehen? Wahrscheinlich schon, oder? Wirklich? Und, positive Bereich? Also du hast wirklich davor noch nie, aber ich meine jetzt ein Bild, hast du davor schon mal ein Bild von Stefan Tietze gesehen? Das ist wirklich das erste Mal, dass du gerade Stefan Tietze siehst. Geil, und? Für dich und wen noch, wen hatten wir noch? Jetzt sind es wesentlich weniger Hände. Es sind komische meine Mehrahne. Außer sprechen mit uns. Dann muss ich jetzt auch aufsteigen. Und ihr werdet noch alle auf die Bühne geholt. Jeder kommt heute auf die Bühne. Macht es lieber wie in der Schule, holt euch lieber bei den einfachen Fragen die mündliche Note, damit ihr nicht gegen Klassenende, dass ihr dann einer der Idioten seid, die die zehn ohne mündliche Note, die dann nochmal, wo es dann hier gegen Stadien gerade geht, wo es dann ein bisschen konfus wird, so dann nochmal die Antworten abholen müssen.
Es gab heute so ein paar Momente, würde ich sagen, so würde ich sie nennen, und zwar hat uns jemand hier von den Veranstaltern plötzlich Handtücher-Backstage gebracht, und aber nicht nur eins, wo man sagt, okay, strange, aber dankeschön, nein, zwei, für jeden, und dann fragt man sich auch ihr wisst schon dass wir der comedy-podcast sind und nicht die Tourengruppe von nächster woche irgendwie ja aber die will ich sagen was braucht man für so einen Podcast viel Wasser und Handtücher primär Stirnbänder, Schweissbänder sowas vielleicht aber nur damit ihr es wisst wir haben ist natürlich heute eine 4D-Veranstaltung also in den richtigen Momenten wird Wasser aus euren Sitzen spritzen, euch direkt ins Gesicht und dem Hintermann ins Gesicht. Ich habe ja meine Zeit lang auf einem Vergügungspark gelebt, also neben einem, ich habe neben einem Vergügungspark gelebt. Ich war eine Woche lang Urlaub in einem Campingplatz und direkt neben einem Vergügungspark, und das ist das Geile war, wenn du in einem Campingplatz gewohnt hast, durftest du kostenlos in den Vergügungstag, solange du wolltest. Und ich war ein junger Mensch, der gerade seinen Körper entdeckt und den Fluch der Gripp-Soundtrack hoch und runter hört. Und da kam es natürlich gelegen, den ganzen Tag... Das 4D-Kino, wo man Johnny Depp live auf der Haut spürt. Und wo ich einfach den ganzen Tag in den Vergütungspark sein konnte, da gab es natürlich so eine Wasserrutsche, so eine Wasserrutsche, die dann sind so ein Wasserding rein und dann werden alle vollgespritzt. Und dann kannst du dich da immer hinstellen, so zu den ganzen Idiotentouristen, die nicht wissen, dass das Wasser so auf die Brücke gespritzt wird und dann nass werden. Und da gab es dann immer Leute, die standen da mit Regenmantel, weil das ist halt so die langweilige Familie, die sagt, komm, wir gehen in den Wildwasserpark, aber wir nehmen eine Regenjacke mit. Ja, das habe ich auch nie verstanden. Die kann man ja kaufen für sehr viel Geld, und da denken sie, das ist eine gute Idee. Aber es ist einfach so, dann lass es einfach. Und es war immer so, da standen dann Leute auf diesem Balkon, die mit Wasser bespritzt wurden, und die Hälfte hatten so Regenmäntel an, und die andere Hälfte nicht. Es war hellig der Sonnenscheintag. Und ich dachte immer, die, die keinen Regenmantel haben, denken die sich nicht so, was passiert hier, was ist hier los, warum tragen alle um mich hier um Regenmantel? Und ich glaube, so ein bisschen ist diese Handtuchssituation auch, dass man sagt, hier sind übrigens eure Handtücher. Und wir, okay, okay. Vielleicht brauchen wir sie noch, die kennen sich besser aus mit Veranstaltungen. Was heute noch kommt, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie... Vor allem diese, ich frage mich bei diesen Fotos vor allem auch immer, die man ja in diesen Rides machen kann, die man am Ende, wo man am Ende noch, vor allem die coolen Leute, habe ich mit so die Frauen gemacht, die coolen Leute wussten schon, dass dann da das Foto gemacht wird und lachen dann schon so mega gut oder haben schon die Peace-Zeichen rausgeholt. Aber sah so ein Foto jemals gut aus, hat jemals jemand gedacht, ja das ist geil, das kann ich für 80 Euro kaufen. Ja vor allem, du hast ja auf diesen Fotos immer, du schaust das Foto an und denkst, ja, okay, geil, ich erst mal. Ja, geil. Und dieser fremde alte Mann vorgut. Meine Mutter und vier fremde fette Menschen, wo man auch sagen muss, dieser Stahlgriff, Figur betont, nicht wirklich so. Nein, nein. Da gibt es bessere Kleidungsstücke. Es waren auch immer die anderen, die schon wussten, dass da eine Kamera ist. Und man selber guckt immer so ein bisschen hoffnungslos rum. Man ist immer selber, man weiss nicht genau. Man selber hat einfach diesen Blick, so ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, dass dieses Gefährt gerade die Schienen verlassen hat. Und alle anderen so, yeee, cool, einfach so. Deswegen, es funktioniert so, man braucht eine grosse Familie, oder du bist der Einzige und der Rest ist so eine perfekte harmonische Familie und du dann so nebenbei so versuchst Anschlüsse finden. Die sind auch eher aus wie die Kinder deiner Eltern als du wahrscheinlich. Ja das stimmt. Du bist der einzige Schwarze. Komisch. Ja viele haben so erst erfahren, dass sie adoptiert wurden, weil sie sich immer dachten so ich passe nicht in diese Fotos rein, alle haben Spaß und ich hab Angst. Was passiert da? Was ist dein Lieblingsfreizeitpark? Geisterbahn? Freizeitpark.
Zuerst die andere Frage interessiert mich jetzt doch noch mehr. Sorry, ich habe mir zwölf Minuten mit Material zu Geisterbahn überlegt. Ich warte nur, ich warte nur bis jemand, ich habe auch geguckt, ob irgendjemand ein Geister auf ein T-Shirt hat oder irgendwie sowas, reinzubringen. Ne, am liebsten mag ich tatsächlich dieses grosse, das Fass hieß es immer, dieses grosse Das war ein Prank, Florian. Das war kein Freizeitfakt. Man hat nicht in ein Fass gesperrt und nicht den Ebersberg runtergerollt. Das war eine Regentonne einfach so. Ja, eine Regentonne. Es war ein grosses Fass, das sich gedreht hat und dann so hin und her gerödelt ist. Okay. Das hat mir Spaß gemacht. Das ist das einzige, woran mich ich erinnere in meiner Vergangenheit. Wir müssen ein bisschen achten, ob nicht Johanna kommt. Die ist sehr flink. Das stimmt. Aber die letzte Reihe... Es ist ja auch wirklich Zeit. Wir hatten erst Angst, dass sie doch pünktlich kommt. Aber hier ist, glaube ich, eine Freundin von ihr, oder? Was ist passiert genau bei ihr? Sie muss länger arbeiten? Sie hat eine Ver gehabt? Wir sind eine Veranstaltung. Wir sind eine Veranstaltung, die man besucht, wo man sich den Abend... Ich habe auch ein bisschen Angst, weil ihr habt euch den Abend freigenommen für uns. Wir sind die abendfüllende Veranstaltung. Das finde ich irgendwie so ein bisschen gruselig. Man muss irgendwie... Man will euch einen guten Abend machen. Ja, weil er tatsächlich sogar auch hier beim Theater angewiesen hat. Wow! Oh Gott!
Nicht schlecht! irgendwie so ein bisschen gruselig, man muss irgendwie, man will nicht einen guten Abend machen. Wow, nicht schlecht. Einen Applaus für Johanna, meine Damen und Herren. Einfach Applaus, sie ist nicht da. Einfach Applaus, es bringt nichts. Aber zum Thema Geisterbahn. Vor allem, jetzt habe ich die falsche Flasche gegriffen und die mache ich jetzt natürlich auch auf. Natürlich, erstmal jede aufmachen und dann einfach, das ist das Conga-Prinzip einfach. Erstmal über jede Conga. Hast du nicht so einen trockenen Mund? Nee, geht. Aber mir geht's so, ich hatte einmal... So Stand-Up-Comedians, die auf der Bühne steht, habt ihr nicht auch immer so einen trockenen Mund? Tun nicht auch eure Beine weh die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen? Das habe ich mal gehört, es war mal auf der Bühne jemand, der so gesagt hat, irgendwie, Ken kennt ihr das in der Bahn? Da wird ja immer gesagt, irgendwie, Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung rechts.
Und man fragt sich so, hä, warum passiert das? Und ich bin aus dem Publikum gerufen, wegen dem Blinden-Arschloch.
Und man fragt sich so, und man...
Aber woher weiss der Blinde, wo rechts ist?
Das war auch meine Frage gewesen. Spüren die das?
Spüren die das? Die können ja auch ... Sehr gut. Sehr gut, das Publikum ist lustiger. Zum Thema ... Ne, ich mag Geisterbahn, so ist es nicht. Ich wollte nicht weg. Bleiben wir bei Geisterbahn. Ich wollte nicht weg von den Geisterbahn. Ich glaube, ich bin wirklich einmal in meinem Leben in der Geisterbahn gefahren als Kind. Und ich habe wirklich meine Augen zugekniffen und mit den Händen meine Ohren abgedeckt, bin einmal durch die Geisterbahn gefahren und saß danach und so, okay, gleich nochmal. Das war geil. Das war richtig geil. Das war geil, da habe ich wirklich ausgehalten. Ey, vor allem, es gibt die Geisterbahn, wo Dinge passieren, wo Fässer umkippen und dann natürlich nicht umkippen, sondern wieder hochgezogen. Diese animatronischen und dann gibt es die mit echten Menschen drin, wo man durchgehen muss. Holy shit, Alter, ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Leute einfach aus Angst den Typen, der auf einen zuläuft und schreit, einfach in die Fresse hauen. Weil man auch denkt, Alter. Aber das mag ich nicht. Das ist das Gute bei Geisterbahnen, dass Geisterbahnen gewisses Pacing haben. Man sieht eine Sache und dann fährt der Wagen weiter und dann kommt das nächste. Bei diesen Räumen ist es dann immer so, du musst so lange in dem Raum warten, bis du keinen Bock mehr hast. Das heißt, du hast Zwangsläufe innerhalb jedes Raums den Punkt, wo du keinen Bock mehr hast. So ist es so, du kommst in den Raum und guckst dir so lange an, bis du denkst, ja okay, das war's und du gehst in den nächsten Raum. Das heißt, du hast für jeden Raum eine kleine Enttäuschung. Ja, vor allem, da gibt es diesen einen Raum, wo man diese, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das kenne, aber diese Metallstangen, die runterhängen und dann ist immer eine, du denkst an eine Feuerwehr, glaube ich, gerade. Man ist in so einer Art Gefängnis und manche von diesen Stangen sind locker, die kann man zur Seite machen und dann kommen so Monster von rechts und links und man muss halt da durch. Aber ich habe als Kind einmal sehr lange nicht die Stange gefunden, die man dann auch machen kann. Und dann war ich wirklich sehr, sehr lange in diesem Raum. Das ist ja die gesamte Pubertät in diesem Stangenraum. Ich glaube, deswegen bin ich so, wie ich jetzt bin. Ach, umherischer Stefan. Ich finde, du hast dich gut entwickelt. Ich finde, ich auch, ja. Ach ja, Johanna, wir müssen auf sie warten, die Schau hat noch nicht begonnen. Und wir müssen auch alles, was wir jetzt gesagt haben, nochmal sagen, sobald Johanna da ist.
Also könnt ihr mitsprechen schon die ganze Zeit.
Also es ist Folge, wir müssen nochmal Leute, also wir veröffentlichen es auch wahrscheinlich als Podcast,
heisst, wir müssen die Leute nochmal mitnehmen und die Hand nehmen, Folge 129 oder sowas.
Es wird langsam echt ernst. Wir haben ja unsere Hörerordnung auch. Das finde ich aber ganz interessant.
Wer von euch glaubt, er ist Hörer der ersten Ordnung heute Abend mal hier?
Oh, der, der gesagt hat, er hat Stefan Tieter noch nie gesehen. Das ist wirklich ein Wenn-Diagramm aus der Hölle. Das gibt's nicht. Wirklich? Lüge. Er ruft einfach Lüge.
Habe ich gelogen, bitte konkretisieren Sie Ihren unhöflichen Ausruf aus der ersten Reihe. Kann jeder sagen, wenn er auch eine Lüge ist. Ja, was meinest du, Lüge? Allgemein erstmal, die Welt im Universum. Lüge! Erstmal skeptisch, Lügen werden erzählt, Lüge! Und die nächste Aussage. Also ihr seid jetzt, das ist offensichtlich kein Hörer der ersten Klasse. Sorry, tut mir leid. Wer noch, erste Klasse, jemand da? Wirklich, hier unentschlossen, keine Ahnung, du kannst alles behaupten, du kannst alles behaupten, wir können das nicht nachprüfen. Hey, ein Applaus für die ersten Ordnung, meine Damen und Herren. Sehr gut, sehr gut, richtig toll, richtig toll. Ich glaube, ich war nie so oft in Verkühlungsparks, glaube ich eigentlich, oder?
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, alle anderen fahren in Verkühlungsparks, aber man selber nicht.
Das war eher sowas, was andere machen.
Richtig, man sieht viele Fotos bei Facebook, wenn man alleine abends zuhause sitzt.
Ja, ich bin, ja, als Kind muss ich Holz fällen, ohne die Kohle-Mine, und alle anderen haben immer Spaß.
Und mit Fässern irgendwelche Berge runterrollen, das war dein Leben, naja. Entweder das oder Donkey Kong. Ich bin mir nicht mehr oder prozessiert. Ich weiss nicht mehr genau. Tolles Konzert. Donkey Kong? Tolles Konzert oder ein Affe in einem Fass? Nein. Nein. Keine Orte. Ich möchte mal ganz kurz den Relatable-Regler ein bisschen hochdrehen. Nineties. Mir ist nämlich eine Gummiband-Bande. Mir ist letztens eine interessante Kategorie aufgefallen, und zwar, das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, aber ich glaube, ihr kriegt es hin. Das schwächste Mitglied ist noch nicht da, Johanna ist noch nicht da, bis jetzt ist der Raum noch stabil. Ich glaube, und zwar Dinge, die immer nur Freunde von einem hatten, aber man selber nicht. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Verstehst du, was ich meine? Dinge, die man selber nicht hatte, aber immer bei Freunden gesehen hat. Wie zum Beispiel, und ich weiß nicht, das ist ja das mit problematisch, weil irgendjemand ist ja auch dieser Freund, der das dann nicht hatte. Aber ich glaube, wir sind alle auf der gleichen Seite. Meine Theorie ist, wir sind alle auf der gleichen Seite. Und zwar, ich hau mal einen raus, etwas, das immer nur Freunde hatten, mehrere verschiedene Cornflakes-Sorten.
Bei mir zu Hause, ja, ja, komm, ja, ja, ja, man kann sich auch so einen Relatable-Applaus mal abholen.
Bei mir war es immer so, bei mir gab es eine Sorte Cornflakes und wenn die zu Ende war, dann kam die nächste Sorte Cornflakes.
Nach einer Stunde. Sorry. Jetzt mit dem Einfall einen Applaus kann ich auch. Du bist auf deinem Boosterboard hingefallen, okay? Ein selbstfahrendem Board. Es fährt von selbst. Bist du auf deine Rolltreppe hingefallen, es fährt von selbst. Ich wollte es erst mitnehmen heute. Ich wollte erst auf ein Boosted Board reinkommen, aber wahrscheinlich wäre ich auf diesen zwei Meter schon hingefallen, zweimal, und ich bin hergeflogen, also kann ich... Ooooooh! Der hätte es wahrscheinlich nicht durch... der hätte es einfach mit dem Boosted Board hierher fahren sollen. Ja, das stimmt, er wäre wahrscheinlich schneller gegangen. Das ist so richtig geil gewesen. Aus Versehen ist es schneller angekommen boosted board garantie glaube ich aber ich weiß nicht ging es ja auch so dass nur andere immer mehrere sorten kommen ich habe auch einen raus ich versuche mal fußballtore im garten okay ja ja finde ich gut niemand hat die niemand kauft die auch und so aber irgendein irgendein cooler vater der anderen das Kind. Oder halt diese, ich weiss nicht, ob das bewusst war, immer diese Kleider trockenen Bügel, die genauso aussahen wie Fussballtore, die einfach so ein grosser Rahmen waren, die man benutzen konnte zum Fussballspielen. Niemand weiß. Also einfach so ein Rechteck, Rechteck, 90 Grad Winkel, ein Rechteck, ein metallisches Rechteck, das im Garten stand. Was ich mich gerade frage... Ich hatte eine merkwürdige Kindheit. Hattest du auch einen imaginären Freund? Ja. Ja, wirklich? Michelangelo von den Turtles. Napoleon. Ja, aber wirklich jetzt? Also man spricht ja, also man sagt, dass es vor allem für Kreativität birgt. Also wenn das Leute, die imaginäre Freunde haben, sind dann kreativer. Ich hatte keinen. Wer hat dir das erzählt? Ich hatte tatsächlich, und es ist mir wirklich etwas unangenehm, das zuzugeben, aber ich hatte eine Zeit lang eine recht innige freudschaftliche Beziehung mit dem Mond. Das ist wirklich kein Witz. Ich hatte, ich hatte, ich habe den Mond als meinen festen Freund betrachtet. Einen festen Freund? Was, glaube ich, so mit das Erbärmlichste ist? Der Mann im Mond oder der Mond? Nee, wirklich straight der Mond. Nee, wenn schon, denn schon. wenn schon, denn schon der Mond. Wer ist der Mann im Mond?
Ich weiss im Mond vor allem.
Weil man da, also wegen der Flecken, dass man denkt, da ist ein Gesicht oder sowas, ne?
Das weiss ich nicht, aber ich hatte eine gute Beziehung.
Ich muss meinen, wenn wir das nächste Mal telefonieren, der Mond und ich.
Ich habe wirklich manchmal im Bett, lage ich im Bett und habe dem Mond gute Nacht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, gute Nacht, Mond.
Was das Falscheste ist, was man dem Mond sagen kann, weil er in der Nacht auf ist. Das mache ich.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Man müsste eigentlich mit gutem Morgen Mond einschlafen, das wäre eigentlich viel besser.
Vor allem hat sich dann auch verwirrt, also ich als Kind war wahnsinnig fasziniert und auch dann so eine Woche lang so apathisch, weil ich nicht verstanden habe, was das sollte, wenn der Mond tagsüber rauskommt.
Ja, das ist ein schlechtes Zeichen. Alter, das ist ein schlechtes Zeichen. Ja, aber was hast du dann gemacht? Warst du nicht verwirrt? Ja, es ist halt so ein bisschen peinlich, wenn halt, sag ich mal, der Freund mit auf die Party kommt, wo man eigentlich alleine sein will, da nicht sehr sehr uncoolen Leute. Du warst schon sehr eng mit der Sonne und plötzlich kam der Mond und man sagt, es ist es nicht das, wonach es aussieht.
Ich hatte keinen imaginären Freund, komischerweise.
Also viele Leute hatten das.
Vielleicht findest du heute Abend einen.
Vielleicht, ich glaube, wir haben viele da, Johanna.
Johanna, das kann gut sein.
Ich glaube, wir haben viele kompetente imaginäre Freunde hier heute da.
Hatte von euch irgendwer einen imaginären Freund?
Okay, hier vorne.
Wer war das? Hatte er einen Namen gehabt?
Felix. Felix. Und war das ein Mensch? Ein Fabelwesen, okay. Ein Fabelwesen namens Felix. Das muss das Gruseligste der Welt sein. Und das sollen die Kreativen sein? Nichts gegen dich, sorry, aber ich mein, sorry, wenn ich Harry Potter schauen würde und dann irgendwie der achte Band oder so und jetzt in Verteidigung gegen die dunklen Dünnese. Ja, jetzt Carsten, weee, weee! Wobei, ganz gut, eine Frage an dich als Star-Wars-Experten, weil es mir gerade kommt, ist mir lange nicht gekommen, aber es gibt ja das Raumschiff von Han Solo. Der Millennium-Falke. Falke? Im Star-Wars-Universum? Gibt es da Falken? Gute Frage. Also gibt es da wirklich einfach normale Falken? Es ist vor allem die Frage, ob es bei Pokémon auch normale Tiere gibt. Ja, gibt es. Es gibt einen Trainer, es gibt den Vogelfänger, glaube ich. Der fängt echte Vögel. Der fängt echte Vögel, weil der hat tatsächlich als Symbol, wenn man gegen ihn kämpft, er benutzt ja nur Vogel-Pokemon und er hat auf der Schulter einen Vogel sitzen. Kein Vogel-Pokemon, einen normalen Spatz. Einfach so einen normalen, so ein Standard-Dude. Wieso soll es den Spatz auf die Schulter setzen, so ein Ibitak, ein wildes Ibitak? Vielleicht gibt er dem Spatz auch manchmal einfach so Befehle und dann denkst du, ach ne, das ist nur ein nur ein scheiß Tier. Und er sperrt sich in so einen Ball ein und ist tot einfach. Schade, hat nicht funktioniert. Vor allem, die müssen ja auch umprobiert haben. Wenn es echte Tiere gibt, müssen die ja umprobiert haben mit diesem Ball. Und es muss ein paar Maschifegange sein. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Es gab eine lange Phase, wo diese Trennung zwischen Tier und Pokémon nicht eindeutig war. Ne, genau. Und da gab es auch bestimmt Initiativen, die dafür gekämpft haben, dass Tiere die gleichen Rechte haben mit Pokémon und so. Kämpft mit Tieren auch, aber macht auch Spaß. Und für die Pokémon auch verwirrend, wenn sie einfach so normale Tiere ansprechen und die einfach nicht reagieren und sie denken, das ist ein bisschen bärtlos einfach. Und der Spatz nicht die ganze Zeit Spatz, Spatz sagt, sondern normal zwitschern. Das stimmt, aber ja, es gibt auch echte Tiere im Pokémon-Universum. Ich habe mich mal gefragt, du kannst ja, also man muss sagen, Ash Ketchum ist ja sozusagen in so einer Ridge-Kitt-Gegend aufgewachsen. Alabastia ist so ein schöner Vorort, so die Gräser ringsum herum sind nicht so richtig gefährlich, da sind die Starter-Pokémon, da kannst du gut trainieren. So wenn du aber in so einer High-Level-Stadt aufwächst und du plötzlich in dieser Geisterstadt und für dein Starter-Pokemon geh mal in diesen 14 Meter hohen Friedhof. Ja, oder am Ende da sauverstörend. Oder wenn du irgendwie am Ende bei dieser Liga da wohnst und einfach rausgehst und da ist so ein Level 99 Turtog, was sich einfach die Fresse wegstrahlt mit diesem Ding. Das muss einfach so eine Art Slum-Gegend sein. Ja, aber du kriegst dann halt von deinem Professor Beich oder wer auch immer, dann in dieser rürierten anderen Welt, kriegst du halt ein dummes Level-3-Schiggy und es wird einfach massakriert von jedem anderen Pokémon. Los, Schiggy, Bats! Also direkt Kopf ab. Kann gut sein, tot leider. Und dann halt Poké Center. Man muss darüber reden, was hinten passiert. Diese Blitze. Jesus Christ. Holy Moly. Das war kein Nieser. Das war ein Gesundheit. Aber ganz kurz, ich möchte nur eine billige Antwort von dir. Welche deutsche Stadt wäre Alabastia? Oh, gute Frage. Welche deutsche Stadt? Ich würde sagen, so ein Vorort von Hamburg oder sowas. Ja? Erfurt? So eine kleine Stadt, so eine schöne Stadt, so eine kleine, also eine ganz normale Gegend, so eine Ridge-Kitt-Gegend, so eine Vorort würde ich sagen. Ich dachte wirklich, die ersten Jahre, die ich Pokémon gespielt habe, dass der gute Ash Ketchup heisst. Ich dachte einfach, der heisst Ash Ketchup. Wie Patty Mayonnaise! Und ich dachte, es kommt alles zusammen. Ich dachte, es kommt alles zusammen. Ich dachte, jetzt funktioniert's. Ich dachte, wir müssen weg vom Pokémon, wir haben ein paar Leute verloren. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend Johanna! Sister! Happy Birthday to you! Happy Birthday to you! Happy Birthday, liebe Johanna! Bitteschön! Happy Birthday to you! Können wir gehen? Ja. Also für euch sind wir durch, jetzt kommt alles nochmal für Johanna. Worauf hast du Bock? Pokémon? Egal. Wie war die Veranstaltung? Welche Veranstaltung hast du gesehen jetzt? Nee, ich hatte lange Wehe. Tipp, früher losgehen. Jeden Tag um sechs aus dem Haus. Egal, wo wir nicht gehen. Ja, ich komme jeden Tag, es gab immer Kinder in der Klasse, die gesagt haben, die jeden Tag Tag so schwer kamen und meinten, ja, ich wohne auch so weit weg von der Schule. Und man sich immer denkt, Leute, das lässt sich nicht lösen, das Problem. Und man als Kind immer dachte, ja, guter Punkt, aber die Eltern, man denkt, ja, wir hätten früher losgehen können. Ja, weiter weg. Ich habe den Bus verpasst, jeden Tag aufs Neue, ganz auszukündigen. Ja, oder nicht. Ich habe den Bus verpasst. Das Geile war, mein Weg zum Bus war wirklich, ich habe den Bus schon gesehen, als ich aus dem Garten rauskam, das Gartentor, dann war ein langer Weg und am Ende hat man den Bus schon gesehen, was furchtbar ist, wenn du den Bus kommen siehst und du musst wirklich einen Kilometer lang einfach rennen und dann bist du schweissgebadet, kommst du an. Ja, vor allem mit diesem Rucksack. Ich glaube wirklich, der beste Sprinter der Welt könnte mit einem schönen Scott, mit einem schönen Scout vollbepockten, ah, Scout, sorry, fuck, komm noch mal rein, Johanna, komm noch mal rein, mit einem schönen Scott, bei mir gab es nur Scott-Rucksäcke, die coolen hatten immer Scott, mit so einem Scott-Rucksack einfach mal die Hälfte der Zeit, das Doppelte der Zeit. Komm noch mal rein mit Garn. Sorry, fuck. Vergiss es einfach. Du hast das Momentum zerstört. Vergiss es einfach. Deswegen meine Regel, ich habe mir einfach irgendwann mal das Gesetz gestellt, niemals Bussen hinterherrennen, niemals U-Bahn hinterherrennen, einfach wenn die nicht kommen, dann kommen sie nicht. Warum hat man dieses Schulbussystem wahrscheinlich durchgesetzt, mit dem gelben dem gelben schulbus wegen den simsons glaube ich glaube das war einfach so ein ding zu lustig so ein deutscher bürgermeister dachte sich das ist schon geil oder das ist schon mega geil kommen das machen wir auch und dann fahren plötzlich schulbüsse auch bürgermeister früher sagst bürgermeister hat in amerikanischen cartoons hat man immer das gefühl bürgermeister ist extrem wichtig für die Stadt. Aber so oft taucht er gar nicht auf im Leben.
Wie gesagt, wir als Klasse durften mal zum Bürgermeister und durften so Vorschläge machen. Und dann habe ich ja gesagt, ja, ich will, dass die Ampel nicht so lange dauert vor der Eisdiele, weil ich immer so lange warten muss vor der Eisdiele. Und seitdem ist immer grün und niemand ganz Ebersberg kann ich mehr Autofahren. Fett Florentin mit seinem Mohnfreund und Piccolo-Eil.
Nicht fucking Pinocchio-Eis, Fickboy-Mannscheine. Mit seinem Scott-Rucksack und Piccolo-Eis. Kein Piccolo für mich einfach. Es war eine wilde Jugend. Während du in deinem Stab... Ja, ich war im Stahlingepack. Ja, kein Bock. Du übernimmst. Aber jetzt geht nicht.
Du trinkst jetzt auch? Wir können nicht gleichzeitig trinken.
Wir müssen Augenkontakt halten und nicht,
wenn ich aufschraube, kannst du nicht auch aufschrauben.
Stefan, auf dich Stefan, auf deine Jungen.
Alles klar, ihr müsst überprüfen.
Ihr merkt schon, es ist eine ganz normale Podcast-Suche-Folge.
Wir haben gedacht, weil wir wollen das ja auch aushauen als, Achtung, als Podcast, es ist eine ganz normale Podcastsuche-Folge.
Das ist nicht so cool. Ey Leute, ich habe seit, ich hatte seit zwei Stunden kein Eis mehr, sorry, ich bin das nicht gewohnt. Ich hatte allerdings, ich habe natürlich Genie, ich habe rote Nudeln gegessen und habe natürlich erst mal 20 Minuten vorm Auftritt mich direkt voll besudelt auf mein T-Shirt-T-Shirt. Und er hat es weggewaschen, Leute, er hat es weggewaschen. Er hat 20 Minuten lang guten Content weggewaschen. Deswegen sage ich es ja jetzt, weil jetzt kann man alles erzählen, aber es klappt heute generell nicht so gut. Ich dachte mir, heute ist eigentlich ein geiler Tag, Live-Show, Leute kommen, heute, weißt du, im Allgemeinen, sag ich mal, denkt man sich ja so, ja, geht so. Aber manchmal denkt man sich auch so, ich hab heute einen geilen Tag. Heute ist ein richtig geiler Tag. Man kommt nur aus dem Bett, Alexa wünscht guten Morgen, creepy. Man lebt auch nicht mehr den ganzen Tag, man lebt so einen Montagetag so. Man sieht nur noch so Wecker klingelt, Uhr drauf, Duschvorhang zugezogen, man lebt das Leben nicht mehr in einer starren linearen Zeit, man ist nur noch in so einem Montagemodus und deswegen habe ich auch den heute. Ich wollte gerade einen Song, weil in diesem Montag läuft immer ein geiler Popsong irgendwie und nicht bis eingefallen It's a Hard Knock Life, das ist der letzte Song, den man bei einem guten Morgen hören will. Nein, it's a good knock life. Was auch immer ein Hard Knock Life. Keine Ahnung, niemand weiss es.el? So, ich liebe dich über alles, ich würde alles für dich tun, ausser... Sorry, sorry, ich hab's nochmal, ich würde alles für dich tun, ausser... Du sagst immer noch, ich erfährst nicht. Was ist das? Strange, but I won't go back, habe ich immer verstanden. Man versteht beispielsweise andere Sachen bei Songs. Ein Kollege von uns, Max, der hat immer erzählt, dass ein Kumpel von ihm bei The Show Must Go On, man kennt den Refrain, The Show Must Go On, das er pathetisch, immer gehört hat, Too much goes on. Oder immer einen Freund hat, der im Club auch immer, gerade wenn der DJ dann so den Song runterfadet, weil alle Leute singen sollen, Too much goes on gesungen hat. Es ist eigentlich ein Song, um die Stimmung ein bisschen runterzuholen. Ja, hier ist zu viel los, hier ist zu viel los, Musik runter, mal kurz. Du kannst ja, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen ein Problem, angenommen, du bist jetzt halt Mr. ACDC, du hast halt eine geile Rockband, aber du willst jetzt halt auch irgendwie eine, sag ich mal, sanfte Botschaft vermitteln, so wie ein, hey Leute, setzt euch mal hin, mir ist gerade ein bisschen schwindelig, so, das ist die Botschaft von deinem Song. Du hast aber nur diese Rockmusik und du hast nur diese Rockinstrumente zur Verfügung. Du musst einen Rocksong schreiben über, hey Leute, stellt euch doch bitte bei der S-Bahn nicht direkt vor den Ausgang. Du musst einen Rocksong schreiben. Du kannst es nicht einfach anfangen. Was wäre die beste Musikart, um so einen Aufklärer vor? Die Top 5 Musikarten. Ich kenne zwei Musikarten. Reggae. Ich kenne Reggae und Scooter. Und mehr alles andere kenne ich.
Scar. Scar, ja, Scar ist sehr gut. Tolle, tolle Band bei uns, viele gute Songs.
Du weißt nicht, was Scar ist. Machen die nicht diese Rucksäcke eigentlich?
Scar. Scar. Aber ich habe, deswegen, weil ich war genau der richtige Instinkt, vielen Dank, Stefan, die jetzt an der, dass ich mir nämlich heute, ich habe wirklich für den Tag mir einen Soundtrack rausgelegt. Ich dachte, ich mache einen Soundtrack für den Tag. Anya only time. Achtung.
Oh, er ist gefährlich.
Ah, Schwerkraft.
Alles gut.
Man kann sich auf Schwerkraft verlassen.
Ich habe mir ein paar Songs herausgesucht, ein paar klassische Zug-Songs, einfach so Train to Istanbul, einfach so klassische Songs. Und dann dachte ich mir, welcher Song ist der Song, wenn man Berlin Hauptbahnhof, man kommt an, Türen gehen auf, man geht raus auf den grossen Platz und man weiß, man ist da. Man ist da. Und ich meine, ich habe eine Zeit lang in Berlin gewohnt, war eine schöne Zeit,
ich habe zusammen mit Lars Paulson in der WG gewohnt, war eine Tollzeit, und ich komme wieder zurück,
da bin ich eigentlich der einzige passende Song, ist The Boys Are Back In Town.
The Boys Are Back In Town, der Mond und ich, der Opa in Berlin. Man muss ja, ich mach's vor, man muss ja den Soundtrack auch immer so ein bisschen leben. Und du denkst dir, okay, du gehst jetzt raus und man ist dann immer so der Moment im Film, wo die Kamera untersichtigt wird und man sieht dann so den ganzen Bahnhof und dann vielleicht so ein Michael, fuck, wie heißt er, Michael Scott? Bublé, ich weiß es nicht. Michael Bublé-artig. Er hat viele gute Kurzfühlen gemacht. Michael Bublé-artigen 360-Grad-Kamerafahrt. Michael Bale. Genau. Man hat alles so rum. Michael Bublé. Und dann hatte ich aber das Problem, dass ich eigentlich ein Car2Go suchen wollte und ich hatte aber in dem Moment kein Internet. Das heisst, ich hatte diesen geilen Song, mach mal den Song, the boys are back in town, the boys are back in town und ich kam raus mit diesem boys are back in town und nur auf meine Hände. The boys are back in town, the boys are back in town, and einfach mit diesem geilen Song auf den Ohren, aber ich konnte es nicht genessen. Die Montage des eigenen Lebens. Es ist einfach, und es hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Es hat gar nicht funktioniert. Ja, Schnürsenkel ist auf, nein. Man macht sie zu, die Wasserflasche war noch offen, ach Gott. Und man denkt sich auch so, okay, wenn man kein Internet hat auf dem Handy, bringt es was, das Handy hochzuhalten? Ist das noch was? Ist das noch was? Macht du das noch? Es ist wahrscheinlich so antrainiert einfach, aber bringt das denn wirklich was? Also früher diese Antennen, die man ausziehen konnte, bringt das irgendwas? Weil ich habe keinen Empfang. Jetzt habe ich Empfang. Ja, also als ob es nicht der, der, wir sagen jetzt mal, der Radioquelle, wo auch immer Radio herkommt, ist ja aus dem Boden, glaube ich. Mast. Es gibt Mast, Mast, ich weiß nicht mehr den Plural. Mast, Mast, der Mast ist ja hunderte, tausende Kilometer gar entfernt. Diese Antenne ist ja scheißegal, aber das ist ja wirklich völlig egal. Weiss ich nicht genau. Vor allem, ich habe ja mal so eine Doku gesehen über Fraktale. Und tatsächlich ist es ja so. Zwei Stunden lang heute schon. Ey, wirklich, sei es... Ohne Scheiss! Und man guckt diese Doku und es wird erklärt, wie das funktioniert. Mit SIM-Karten und so, dass die immer kleiner werden konnten, weil man einfach immer... Man hat die gleiche Technik genommen nur halt mit Fraktale ist einfach das ein kleineres Vielfache von etwas hat man dann genommen und dann wurde es und dann und dann wanderte der Cursor auf einen anderen Tab. Mal gucken, was Johanna so auf Felschwein macht. Ja und dann hat es genauso funktioniert und man kennt das ja, man sieht von der Doku und denkt so, ja, genau so, funktioniert das mega gut. Ich habe nichts einzuwenden, einmal der Baller, du hast wirklich Ahnung. Und dann sitzt man hier, tipptopp, ich habe nichts, kein Einfach. Ich habe alles verstanden und dann sitzt man in so einer Show und erzählt davon und man weiß nicht mehr genau, wie es lief, weil man erzählt Freunden davon und denkt sich, wie war das genau? Letztlich wollte man einfach nur das Wort Fraktale einmal benutzen. Weil man ein schönes Wort. Es ist ein Wort, vor allem ist es so kompliziert, dass niemand nachfragt. Es gibt gewisse Begriffe, da wird man klug, aber Leute fragen nach und man hat keine Ahnung. Fraktale denken sich alle so, ja, ich habe keine. Das ist ein ganz transzendentales Ereignis gewesen, muss man einfach sagen. Ich glaube, es kommt noch ein bisschen darauf an, wie selbstbewusst man das ausspricht und wie selbstbewusst man das sagt. Und wenn man so ganz normal das in Gespräch einfließen lässt, dann akzeptiert man das glaube ich auch als gegenüber und stellt sich in Frage. Und man meint es auch müssen zu müssen. Und dann merkt man schon, wenn der andere so cheatet. Ja, klar, ich weiß nicht, weil sie von dem Sprechen. Ich glaube, wir alle cheaten. Ich glaube, immer alle blöffen konstant. Und jedes ... Das ist genau einfach wie immer. Jeder cheatet. Ausser Stephen Hawking.
Der wusste wirklich Bescheid oder hat die ganze Zeit gegoogelt. Wusste er das alles selber? Wenn ein Mann uns verarschen kann, dann der, der eh die ganze Zeit einen Computer angeschlossen wird. Das stimmt schon, ja. Das stimmt. Aber er wusste doch nichts.. Ist ja eine verrückte Geschichte, dem wurde ja irgendwie mit, mit 14, mit 20 prophezeit, du hast noch irgendwie 20 Minuten zu leben, aber dann hat er irgendwie, ist er noch bis 70 geworden. Aber ist er, ist er jetzt eigentlich, ist er jetzt eigentlich an seiner, ist er an seiner, ist er eigentlich an seiner Krankheit gestorben oder war das jetzt ein ganz dummer Bootsunfall? Hausarbeitsunfall, ja. Und dann ist das Klavier einfach aus dem dritten Stock ausgerechnet auf Herrn Hawking. Ich habe gesagt, ich will eigentlich oben tragen, weil es einfach... Aber dann, konnt ihr nicht wissen, dass der weltberühmte Astrophysiker... Leute, sie lieben Callbacks. Ich hab's dir gesagt. Entschuldigung. Ich hab's dir gesagt. Es sieht schon aus wie Scheisse, die ganzen Flaschen liegen hier rum einfach. Ich sitze halb auf den Kabeln. Ist jetzt die Zeit eigentlich für das erste Handtuch? Wollen wir das erste Handtuch machen? Nee, brauchst du schon Handtuch? Komm, nein, jetzt war Handtuch, oder? Ich finde es so viel von Handtuch. Aufgepasst, Freunde. Hier ist das erste Handtuch. Geil. Können wir die behalten, dann nachher? Das war das erste Handt hoch. Sehr gut. Freut dich aufs Zweite. Ja, Stephen Hawking war ein grosser Mann, auch tolle Werke, die er geschrieben hat. Toll. Also besonders die Vorworte fand ich immer sehr. Sehr, also die Fässerregister. Der Glossar, ja, Glossar. Das Glossar! Der? Ich weiss wirklich nicht, das Glossar? Glossar? Ich weiss nicht mehr genau, was es ist. Ist das mit dem von A bis Z die Begriffe, die drin vorkommen? Nee, Dossier meinst du, oder? Das Wort und finden sie auf Seiten zwei, drei, vier. Das ist ein gutes Buch, also vier Seiten Text und dann nur noch Glossar. Ja, vor allem, wer entscheidet im Glossar, also welche Glossar-Autoren, wie entscheiden die sich, warum Wörter es verdienen, in den Glossar zu kommen? Johanna, Idee, hast du eine Idee? Gar nichts? Überhaupt nichts?
Bräuchst du schon den langen Weg auf dich genommen zu haben?
Toll, ich würde in meinem Buch, egal welches Buch ich mal schreiben werde, vielleicht werde ich es ein Buch schreiben.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall Gutscheine beilegen, weil jeder liebt Gutscheine, jeder liebt Gutscheine.
Und stell dir vor, du hast so ein Buch, wo auf jeder zehnten Seite ein schöner Gutschein ist. Ein schöner Milchshake bei McDonalds. Einfach so und denkst du, geil!
Ich lese weiter, die Story interessiert mich nicht, kleine Junge, der in so ein Erdloch reingeht und dann ist er in so einer magischen Welt, wo man statt Flammen sprechen können und Menschen nicht. Und so, man denkt sich, ja, oder so.
Oder so ein 3D-Faltbild, aber es ist ein normales Buch.
Ein ganz normales Buch und irgendwann auf Seite 128 denkt man, what, und plötzlich kommt so eine Stadt einem entgegen.
Das ist geil.
Ich finde nur wie geil, aber ich finde es mega geil. Ich habe letztens mir Strom besorgt und kann ich also weiterempfehlen, ist eine gute Sache. Und dann konnte ich da so Sachen ankreuzen, was ich haben will. Strom, seit 1500, nein, sorry, tut mir leid, ich weiß nicht. Und dann konnte ich da so Sachen ankreuzenuzen was ich haben will und dann stand da auch dann so dieses klassische ökostrom 20 euro mehr im monat das ist das sind die momente wo man die laptop kamera vorab klebt genau das habe ich aber wirklich entweder man macht es nach dem Kauf direkt oder an einem
wierenden Moment. Also niemand macht, niemand sitzt so normal bei seinen Steuersachen und
sagt, ja die Laptopkamera mach ich ab. Niemand will das machen. Das ist eine To-Do-Liste, muss ich heute noch mal ein Laptop abkleben.
Das stimmt. Hast du die abgeklebt? Ne, nicht abgeklebt, aber Angst. Ich denke mir, ich habe Angst die ganze Zeit, aber ich
ändere nichts daran, zu faul. Ich denke mir, da ist ja diese grüne Lampe daneben und die wird schon angehen, wenn die... Also die ist ja immer an, die ist ja immer an, wenn die an ist. Das stimmt, das kriegen die auch nicht umgangen, die Hacker, das schaffen die nicht. Die können Bitcoins hacken oder... Vor allem, dann denke ich mir, manchmal kommt man ja, wenn man Mac hat... Komm, ist gut, alles gut, alles gut. Ich habe doch keine Ahnung, man. Nee, komm, ey, die sind gut drauf. Wir haben drüber gesprochen. Wenn man bei Mac, kennt das vielleicht, wenn man auf FaceTime aus Versehen kommt und man muss sich plötzlich selber sehen. Und dann denke ich mir auch, warum sollte ich die Laptop-Kamera abkleben? Ich drücke mich selber sofort wieder weg. Und ich fahre mich auch im Spiegel an und so, also ich bin es gewohnt, mich zu sehen und so weiter, aber ich drücke mich selber sofort wieder weg. Warum Warum soll ich die Laptopkamera abkleben, niemand will das sehen. Man muss das einmal die Woche testen, so kurz die Kamera auf, so okay, immer noch schrecklich, keine Angst vor der NSA. Ja, oder zwischendurch mal einmal in die Kamera gucken und sagen, ja, ich weiß, dass ihr da seid. Ja, genau, das hassen die, das hassen die total, das können die nicht ertragen. Ah, Tietze, er hat mich schon wie die ganze NSA, er weiss es, er weiss es!
Mal ganz blöd, können die, nee sorry, mal komplett, ich dachte, können die nicht die Kamera so machen, dass man durchgucken kann, das kriegen die schon hin irgendwo die NSA.
Hä? Man kann doch, aber warum klebt man das Mikrofon nicht ab, weil dann können die ja so sagen so, nimm mal das Ding ab. Und dann kann man nichts machen. Vor allem gibt's dann, hab ich jetzt neulich gesehen, das ist ein neuer Laptop, den man kaufen kann, wo man vorne so ein kleines Rad und dann bildet sich so eine Linse, wie man das von Fotoapparaten kennt, die schiebt sich dann so vor die Kamera. Aber dann denk ich mir... Bei einem Laptop? Mhm, mhm. Aber dann kann man ja nicht mehr...
Dann lass mal die Stimme den ganzen Abend... Aber dann kann man ja nicht mehr zuklappen, oder was? Was? Dann kann man den Laptop nicht mehr zuklappen, wenn man das so rauskommt. Natürlich kann man den auch zuklappen. Du kannst einfach oben so eine kleine, da kannst du so ein Ding drehen, dann sieht man nichts mehr. Du kannst quasi das Taschentuch, das du davor klebst, das hast du schon eingebaut da drin quasi. Das ist ganz geil, aber ich denke mir auch, das baut ja der Laptop-Hersteller rein. Ja, und dann kann man da durchgucken. Ja, genau! Das ist geil, das ist clever. Irgendwann machen die auch unsichtbare Kameras so daneben, die man nicht sieht, wo man dann wirklich dann so alles abkleben muss. Beim iPhone ist es ja schon so, man sieht die ja nicht so richtig gut. Ja, fuck, ne, wie weit die Technik geht. Crazy, crazy, crazy. Ich find's schrecklich. Aber ich bin bei sowas sehr schmerzfrei. Also ich denk mir so, was wollen die denn machen, wenn sie mich sehen? Also auch, ich habe neulich meine Sparkassenkarte verloren und ich hab schon Leute erlebt, die dann richtig nervös wurden. Und auch dachten, jetzt kann jeder was Geld abheben und so, aber du kannst ja relativ schnell anrufen, die sperren lassen, dann ist gut. Also es kann ja nicht so richtig viel passieren und das Geld kannst du auch wieder zurückbekommen und sowas. Und dann habe ich, was total geil ist, trotzdem mal geguckt, ob die vielleicht irgendwo im Fundbüro abgegeben wurde. Und man kann sich alle Sachen, die im Fundbüro in Köln, wahrscheinlich auch, angucken im Internet. Wie Fotos? Es gibt ein Register, nein, nein, es gibt ein Register mit allen Dingen, die irgendeinem... Fotos, Fotos, Fotos! Warum sind wir jetzt so mittlerweile? Man kann sich alle Dinge, die jemals abgegeben worden sind in letzter Zeit, in einem Fundbüro angucken in Köln. Also wirklich so die letzten, so die zehn Browserverlauf? Es ist sortiert, wirklich. Wie Zalando zum Beispiel. Klamotten, dann kannst du auf Herren gehen, dann auf Schal, und du siehst alle Schals, die abgegeben wurden in Köln. Total geil! Und dann ist ja auch eine Beschreibung von diesem Schal, damit man es selber findet. Man könnte dann denke ich mir hingehen und sagen, ja ich vermisse einen Schal, einen schwarzen Schal. Für Herren. Der ist Grösse unisex, normale Unigrösse und dann kannst du das abholen. Marke Unbekannt, sagt dir das man? Ja, aber wahrscheinlich kann man das so machen. Sehr interessant. Ey, Fundbüro ist sowieso wirklich ein grosser Riss in der Gesellschaft, den niemand ausnutzt. Ich glaube, da kann man eine Serie drüber schreiben, ohne Scheiss. Ich glaube, über Fundbüro, das fehlt mir an Breaking Bad, dass die nichts mit Fundbüro machen. Leute, ihr habt eine Serie, ihr habt die Schauspieler schon am Set, die sind da schon, die Kameras
hau...
Die haben schon Kostüme an, Leute.
Ihr habt, da steht schon Catering, ihr habt schon Leute, das Mikrofon läuft, dann
sag doch mal was zum Fundbüro, Leute.
Ich denke mir so, wie bescheuert kann man sein?
Das ist der Special Interest Regisseur, der hier Drehpause nutzt.
Könnt ihr noch mal diese kleine Szene spielen?
Genau, einfach so.
Oder einfach nur das Wort Fundbüro.
Sag mal Fundbüro. Und hast du dir schon was geholt, hast du was gesehen, was dir gefällt? Nee. Nichts, du hast eine ganze Liste von Gegenständen und dir. Du bist ein sehr zufriedener Mensch. Das Ding ist, ich glaube, wichtige Dinge und vor allem coole Dinge werden schnell wieder abgeholt. Entweder von Leuten, die diese Seite kennen und genau diesen Trick anwenden, oder aber von Leuten, die sofort bemerken, dass sie es verloren haben, glaube ich. Ich habe meinen iPod verloren und tatsächlich hat jemand den iPod gefunden in dem Car2Go und hat die Fotos sich anscheinend angeschaut, hat mich erkannt und hat mich angeschrieben auf Facebook, hey, ich habe deinen iPod. Und das war so ein wirklich so... Überweise eine Million Dollar. Ja, aber das war wirklich so ein glattes Fifty-Fifty-Gefühl, so geil, oh fuck, der kennt mich und er hat alle meine Fotos. Und das ist wirklich so der Moment, er hat keinen Tweet abgesetzt, und ich sag mal, die allgemeine Gedächtnisleistung variiert ja stark, so man, ich habe mich, den Namen meiner Mutter, keine Ahnung, gar keine Ahnung, so aber in dem Moment, in dem jemand sagt, hey, ich habe dein iPod, hast du plötzlich die Gedächtnisleistung eines späten Stephen Hawking, der einfach bam alle, alle möglichen Momente, in denen Foto gemacht wurde, plötzlich wieder vor Augen hat und man denkt sich, die Kamera war nicht abgeklebt. Die war grö, für die meisten Fotos war die Kamera nicht abgeklebt. Das stimmt. Hast du mal ein Nacktfoto von dir gemacht? Ja. Ja, durchaus. Aber ganz schwierig, ne? Ganz Körper oder nur aufs Wesentliche beschränkt? Nee, nicht, also Gesicht nicht. Da bin ich schon... Ich dachte, du bist nackt und Fotografist nur dein Gesicht. Hm, zehn Statt Nacktfoto? Ey, ernsthaft, glaubst du, wenn man dir zehn Bilder zeigt von zehn Gesichtern und man sagt dir, fünf Leute sind gerade nackt, könnte man das rauslesen? ich glaube das führt in die leere aber es wird locker eine gute Galileo mystery folge sein locker kein brot ein Mann wenn du da bist schreibt mit ist alles umsonst wo ist Galileo mystery haben die alles gelöst alle Rätsel gelöst wird dann eigentlich Illuminaten ist egal die müssen wir von vorne fahren die machen noch mal Turiner Grabtuch so haben wir 2008 eigentlich schon geklärt, aber jetzt hier, falls sich was verändert hat, machen wir nochmal.
Ja, schade, dass solche Sendungen nicht mehr gibt. Auch hier sowas wie Next Uri Geller und sowas, das fand ich immer toll. Ja, wer ist der Next Uri Geller? Ja, wer ist es eigentlich jetzt? Wer ist der Nächste? Ich weiß es nicht. Der mit dem Raben, glaube ich. Der Blonde mit dem Raben, der war mega gut. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich bin gerade im Prozess, alle meine DVDs, die ich besitze, zu digitalisieren, legal. Und deswegen schaue ich mir die ganze DVD-Sammlung gerade durch und auch obskure Sachen. Und ich habe eine DVD zu Uri Geller. Irgendwann hat mir mal jemand eine DVD zu Uri Geller geschenkt. Aber sie ist verbogen. Genau, kann nicht abgespielt werden, weil verbogen, Zwinker-Smiley. Cool, 14 Euro für nichts, für diesen Gang. Prank, ist ein Prankster. Aber tatsächlich hat mir irgend jemand mal eine DVD zu Uri Geller geschenkt, was einem auch so die Frage stellt, was war ich früher für ein Mensch, was war ich? Welchen Menschen denkt man so, weißt du, dass ich genau das richtige geschenkt habe, ich habe genau das richtige geschenkt für dich, Uri, es gibt nur eine Uri, ich muss eine Uri sagen, es gibt keinen zweiten Uri. Aber dann sollte man doch bei dieser Show oder generell bei allen seinen Shows, sollte man dann die Uhren auf den Fernseher legen, die dann anhalten. Ja. Das ist schon gut. Man muss sagen, das ist schon eine Leistung auf der Art. Ich könnte es nicht. Wenn ich jetzt sage, legt zuhause mal eure Uhr auf das Abspielmedium. Ich glaube, sie würde weiterlaufen. Es gibt ja diese Online-Kurse, diese Masterclasses, so Screenwriting, Filmmusik. Gibt es das auch mit Comedy, Judd Apatow, also gibt es noch zwei Wochen und dann haben wir es drauf. Aber da fände ich Uri Geller geil. So die Uri Geller, hoffe Uri Geller ist nicht tot und wir jetzt nicht die ganzen... Nee, Stephen Hawking ist tot, Uri Geller lebt noch. Das sind die beiden Namen, die du merken. Okay, fuck, sorry. Aber tatsächlich gibt es ja den Magier mit der Maske. Das ist so ein bisschen die Masterclass, oder er hat es so ein bisschen raus. Boah, der muss gehasst werden. Naja, vielleicht ist das auch Uri Geller, er weiß. Oder ist es Banksy, das wäre der Reveal des Jahrhunderts. Ich bin Banksy und ich bin der Magier mit der Maske, fickt euch, tschüss. Das ist nicht schlecht. Wenn alle mysteriösen Leute dieselbe Person sind. Zu dieser Person, die Siri gesprochen hat oder so, all diese berühmten Persönlichkeiten. Das ist bestimmt wahnsinnig nervig für diese Person, wenn die zu lange auf ihren Ausknopf kommt. Ja, ja. Die ganzen Xylophon-Leute, die immer den Klingelton spielen müssen, einfach von Alper-Al. Ach so, mir haben viele Leute, ich habe jetzt aus Versehen mir eine Alexa gekauft. Dein Siri hat aus Versehen eine Alexa gekauft, sich einsam gefühlt. Ja, und die bestellen die ganze Zeit Dinge und es ist auch nervig. Ja, und quatschen die ganze Zeit so. Die ganze Zeit, nachts nervig. Und dann haben wir viele Artikel geschickt über Alexa, die nachts, da gab es so einen Bug, und nachts haben die angefangen zu lachen ganz laut.
Warte mal ganz kurz. Und ist das nicht das russische?
Hörst du die tropische Musik gerade? Sind wir gerade mitten in Topical Island eigentlich?
Wirklich?
Ich glaube, wir sind gerade mitten in Topical Island.
Topical Island, Topical Island.
Habt ihr mitbekommen, in letzter Zeit häufen sich die Schlagzeilen.
Alexa lacht nachts. Oh mein Gott, das ist wirklich ganz schön creepy. Vor allem, wenn man würde aufwachen zu der lachenden Alexa, hoi shit. Ganz kurz, ich tecke es nicht, warum hat Alexa denn überhaupt lachen ist es dann so ein haa oder ist es wirklich so ein echtes lachen weil ich
habe es leider nicht gehabt ich habe mich gefreut darüber. Das wäre aber eine coole Story für so einen Podcast. Da würde endlich mal jemand lachen bei dir. Wow, sorry. Entschuldigung, er hat Krefeld noch nicht verkraftet, es tut mir leid. Hey, ist doch okay. Krefeld war nicht gut. Kommt jemand aus Krefeld? War jemand da? Das traut sich jetzt niemand. Das traut sich niemand. Es war ein Stand-Up-Auftritt von mir, der hat nicht funktioniert bisschen, der war ein bisschen dark, der war ein paar Sachen, die waren ein bisschen zu dark, deswegen sind wir heute sehr clean und benutzen keine, haben Hitler schon fertig quasi. Und wir haben die Marionetten zu Hause gelassen, das war nicht die beste Idee, weil es der eine. Die Leute haben vorher eine Liste bekommen mit Dingen, die ich nicht machen soll, glaube ich kriegt jeder, aber auch nur ich, die bekommen, aber eine Liste mit Dingen, die man nicht machen sollte, keine Puppen mitnehmen, nicht fragen, wie viel Zeit man noch hat und sowas. Aber ich dachte mir, es wäre geil, so jetzt sieben Minuten für euch, Stefan, und ich komme auf die Bühne und frage, wie viel Zeit ich noch habe. Ja, das ist einfach als erstes, fick dich so. Unangenehm, kriegst du eine Liste mit Dingen, die man nicht machen sollte. Ich finde gut, kommen die Rebellen, die niemand kennt. Einfach so, du rebellierst gegen das System, aber wen interessiert? Nobody cares. Es gibt bestimmt auch Musiker, die total verrückte, gesetzesbrechende Musik machen,
also interessiert einfach keinen. Dann ist da die Rebellion auch nichts.
Hast du mal rebelliert eigentlich? Ist unsere Generation nicht so richtig, ne? Wäre sie keine Rebellen.
Hat ihm ja von euch mal rebelliert, würde er das sagen von sich?
Das ist ne...
Das klang nach einem sehr souveränen, ich hab mal rebelliert Schrei.
Das war, ja. Ich bin zehn Minuten später zu Hause angekommen, als meine Mutter es mir erlaubt hat. Wooo! Yes! Ich glaube, ich habe wirklich nie rebelliert. Auch weil ich alles durfte. Ich war das dritte Kind von drei. Es war wirklich so, hey, wir haben gelernt, die überleben schon. So ist scheißegal, mach was du willst, und dürfte ich auch so mehr oder weniger. Und ich wollte nicht viel. Ich glaube, je mehr man darf, desto weniger will man. Verstehst du, das ist so genau das, was man... Das ist eigentlich die beste Erziehungsmethode, seinen Kindern einfach alles zu erlauben, so dass sie sagen, ja, dann macht es auch keinen Spaß. Anti-Autoriter. So die in die Rebellion nehmen, um die zu brechen, einfach so. Man kann Kinder brechen, man kann furchtbare Sachen machen, man kann den Wörtern nicht beibringen, man kann den falschen Wörtern beibringen.
Die Zahlen falsch rum. Einfach sieben und acht, immer vertauschen. Einfach alles Gute zum achten Geburtstag. Oder das römische Zahlensystem beibringen. Und es kommt in der Schule an und denkt sich, what? Hahaha, ich bin schon VIII Jahre alt.
Alle Freak.
Mein bester Freund ist Luna.
Oh, Latein, LK. Ich bin schon VIII Jahre alt. Alle Freak.
Oh, Latein-LK.
Oh, hey!
Das war Topical Island.
Dankeschön.
Kommt an.
Benutzt du Alexa regelmäßig, also wirklich so, wenn du Musiker hast?
Nee, ich hab jetzt, um sie regelmäßig zu benutzen, habe ich mir von der Marke Philips, habe ich mir Glühbirn, kein Grund, dass sie erwähnen.
Wir müssen noch After-Aid und Seidenwacher erwähnen, dann haben wir es auch.
Habe ich mir diese Lampen gekauft, die man dann einfach, die sich mit dem Internet verbinden, und man kann damit dann quasi ein Smart Home, und es ist meine Küche und mein Schlafzimmer sprachgesteuert, was sau nervig ist, weil man
muss dazu sagen, einen Lichtschalter zu drücken ist nicht besonders schwierig. Es geht sehr schnell und ist vor allem im Körper drin dieses, also man macht ja nicht mehr, sondern ist schon so, man kommt rein und haut so nebenbei, macht man das Licht an und jetzt muss man sich konditionieren, dass man sagt Alexa, Alexa, Alexa das Licht mit dem Schlafzimmer. Ich habe dich nicht verstanden. Ich habe Licht im Schlafzimmer nicht gefunden. Lach dich nur auf. Fick dich! Aber zum Thema Sprachsteuerung, ich habe momentan recht viel Zeit und ich dachte mir, fang was damit an und lerne Klavier spielen.
Er hat gestern gesagt, er hatte in den letzten Tagen viel um die Ohren, wo man sich fragt, was war los, Müll rausbringen, was war... Weil ich viel Klavier gespielt habe. Und da habe ich mir auch so eine Software runtergeladen, die dann so die Töne erkennt und dann gibt er dir hier so, keine Ahnung, Coldplay, dieses... Und dann ist es so beliebteste Songs und der Song eins ist Amelie und dann denk dir, nee, auf keinen Fall, Song zwei ist Coldplay, ja okay, Coldplay. Was macht die Software? Die erkennt, was du für Töne spielst auf dem Klavier und dann gibt ihr diese Noten und dann sagt die richtig oder falsch und so. Ich hab's nicht hingekriegt, obwohl ich ein E-Piano hab, nicht es anzuschliessen, hab ich nicht hinbekommen, deswegen musste ich so das Mikrofon machen, erst mal schön Klebestreifen und Mikrofon abgezogen und dann konnte ich es wieder nutzen. Aber strange. Und dann hat er es so erkannt und das Problem war, dass ich immer die Töne nicht richtig getroffen habe und dann laut geflucht habe und die Spracherkennung oft mein lautes Fluchen als richtigen Tode erkannt hat. Das ist ein Böse Onkels-Song. Er will und dann spricht Diddl diddl de fuck fick dich okay fuck fick fick dich fuck you fuck oder einfach so kommt man durch einen song durch weil ich es anscheinend hinkriege in genau den richtigen ton lagen zu fluchen aber heißt das du kannst damit auch komponieren also du kannst sozusagen also man sagt die tabu ja nach dass er gerne mal einen song nimmt quasi schon existiert der ist. Ich weiss, Leute, behalten wir es für euch. Das hört ihr nirgendwo anders, Leute. Und dann quasi leicht verändert, um dann quasi einen erfolgreichen Song zu machen. Das ist ein Stressig. Und ich denke mir, der müsste die Software benutzen, um dann zu erfahren, wann er quasi plagiert und wann nicht. Weil die Software sagt, falsch, falscher Ton. Du meinst, wie man sich bei YouTube Filme in halber Geschwindigkeit angucken kann, wo der dumme Algorithmus, der so scheisse dumm, ist es immer noch Ritter aus Leidenschaft, nur halt langsam, aber er checkt es halt nicht. Und dann kann man den ganzen Film in halber Geschwindigkeit anschauen, damit der Algorithmus nicht checkt, was es ist. Ich finde es so clever, Podcasts in doppelter Geschwindigkeit abzuspielen. Du sparst Zeit. Man spart Zeit. Und mehr Gags in doppelter Geschwindigkeit. Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, mir ist gerade etwas aufgefallen im Publikum. Was ist dir aufgefallen? Und zwar, dass bei Ritter aus Leidenschaft niemand geklatscht hat. Aber Ritter aus Leidenschaft ist ein richtig geiler Film. Ach, kommt schon, ey. Ey, würde ich... Und daher kommt nämlich auch The Boys are back in town, weil ich gerade den Ritter aus Leidenschaft... Ich will jetzt den Ritter aus Leidenschaft. Ey, ich liebe die letzten Tage schaue ich. Ritter aus Leidenschaft ist einfach ein Film, der macht einfach Spaß. Ich glaube, da würde selbst der Eloquenteste, der würde selbst Wolfgang Schmidt sagen, weißt du was, der bockt einfach so. Der macht einfach... Das ist ein geiler Scheißer. Der ist einfach geil. Und da gibt es auch The Boys Are Back in Town und es gibt einen Song, den ihr wahrscheinlich kennt, Sweet Home Alabama.
Guter Song, ich bin musikalisch noch ein paar Jahre hinterher.
Und Sweet Home Alabama fängt wirklich an mit Gitarre, glaube ich, nennt man das.
Und dann sagt in den ersten drei Sekunden des Songs jemand, turn it up, sagt jemand während des Songs, wo ich mir beim Hören dachte so, chill ein bisschen, okay, ist ein geiler Song, wissen wir alle, aber du musst nicht in deinem eigenen Song so, mach mal lauter, geiler Song, einfach so, chill, du bist Sweet Home Alabama, jeder kennt den Song. Ich glaube, wie Jason DiRulo in seinem Song singt am Anfang Jason DiRulo, das ist ein geiler Song, mach mal ein bisschen lauter jetzt, sorry.
Was keinen Sinn macht, dass er Werbung für sich selber macht, in einem Song, den er schon singt, den man schon hört. Das ist das Merkwürdige, so wie immer, wenn bei McDonalds, McDonalds-Werbung läuft. Man geht raus und straight wieder rein, einfach so, ich liebe diesen Laden, einfach. Das Beste, also meine soziale Phobie ist so befriedigt bei McDonalds jetzt, weil man
kann am Automaten bestellen.
Und das Beste ist, du kannst am Automaten bestellen und an der Kasse bezahlen.
Heißt, du kannst sozusagen, du sparst dir, es ist mega unangenehm, weil du sagst dem
Typen, der Bedienung quasi direkt ins Gesicht, ich will nicht mit dir reden, aber ich will
auch nicht viel daran in der Situation ändern. Also bestelle ich am Automaten, gehe dem Typen das Geld, nimm das Paket in die Hand und gehe. Ich habe wirklich da immer so ein schlechtes Gewissen, immer wenn ich an diesen Automaten eintippe. Ich fange gerade an diesem Gerät, was seinen Job bald ablöst. Ja, ich sehe immer, während ich eintippe im Hintergrund die Kassiererin, die so Bilder von ihren Kindern hochhält, einfach so. Einfach nur so starre in die Augen schaut und nicht so, ja sorry, aber manche Soßen gibt's
nur hier einfach so, sorry.
Stimmt das?
Ja.
Wirklich jetzt?
Vor allem, sorry, kleiner Life-Fact.
Man fängt die so an, ihre eigene Soße zu machen, weil die so selbstgebackene Waffeln
haben wir hier auch.
Ihr könnt übrigens auch McDonald's T-Shirts kaufen am Merchstand nach der Vorschung.
Man kann tatsächlich, und das ist wirklich kein Witz und das ist ein Life-Fact, den ich euch mitgeben möchte, man kann beim klassischen McDonald's-Menü, ja, kennt jeder Burger, Pommes, Getränk, man kann zum Beispiel Burger zwei Pommes nehmen. Ja? Ja, wirklich kein Scheiß, man kann wirklich statt des Getränks eine zweite Pommes nehmen. Man kann sagen, Burger zwei Getränke. Man geht einfach mit zwei Getränke. Ist wirklich, ist ja völlig ruhig, ihr könnt es nicht fassen, es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich hundertprozentig so. Ihr könnt an dem Automaten, könnt ihr sagen, scheiß auf die Cola lei, die nimmt mir eh nur Kalorien weg, will ich nicht, noch eine schöne zweite grosse Pommes dazu. Und es ist der gleiche Preis, es ist der gleiche Preis. Wir verteilen Gutscheine am Ausgang für McDonalds, könnt ihr einfach direkt... Aber zurück zu Ritter aus Leidenschaft. Zurück aus Leidenschaft. Es ist einfach ein guter Film, der Spaß macht. Ach so, das war... Das war... Mir wollte ich gar nicht sagen. Auch Ritter aus Leidenschaft. Ja, ist ein guter Film. Ja, ist ein guter Film. Hier ist Ledger. Mit dem Jungen hieß Ledger. Viele Leute sagen ja, Dark Knight war seine beste Rolle. Nope. Ritter aus Leidenschaft. Da streite ich mich mit jedem. Ritter aus Leidenschaft. Muss man eigentlich so eine Schweigeminute für Stephen Hawking machen? Oder kommen heute Abend noch ein paar Schweigeminuten von sich, von uns aus, ganz natürlich in dem Abend? Wir erklären ab jetzt jede peinliche Pause rückwirkend als Schweigeminute für Stephen Hawking. Dann passt's auch eigentlich. Wie ist er jetzt gestorben? Ich weiss es nicht, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Ich dachte, das wäre ein Gag, als du mir das erzählt hast. Ob soll ich aber schwer Schätze machen? Das ist furchtbar. Ja. Ja, man kann meinen, du findest es nicht furchtbar. Nein, nein. Du, Steve und ich hatten eine innige Beziehung. Und der war auch wirklich lustig, der hat ja dieses tolle Interview mit Jean-Oliver geführt, wo er wirklich fantastisch war, wo man sich fragt, hat er die Gags schon, also googelt er die Gags nebenbei, ist halt diese Frage. Und wie viel Zeit vergeht er immer, ne? Man denkt ja immer, wow, die sind so witty, die sind so lustig, aber da sind ja teilweise zwei, drei Stunden Denkpause dazwischen, weil du kannst ja nicht, du kannst ja Steve-Walking nicht eine Frage stellen und dann nach fünf Minuten so, okay, die nächste Frage. Du musst ja warten, egal wie lange es dauert. Die Antwort interessiert mich gar nicht mehr so sehr. Aber wie hat er jetzt genau geschrieben? Also hat er dann, also Theorie 1, Augen. Er hatte so eine Tastatur und dann gibt es ja diese Augen-Tracker und er hat dann geguckt und dann sozusagen immer selber eingetippt oder hatte der quasi so ein Advanced-System, was man halt auch diese Sprache, diese Wortvorstellung, die man auch bei... War der nicht so krass, dass der mit Gedanken seinen Rollstuhl... Also jetzt nicht... Hey Leute, ihr schaut zu wenig YouTube-Videos, es ist möglich, es ist möglich, man kann mit Gedanken Sachen steuern.
Es gibt so einen Typen, der hat so einen Roboterarm und der sagt, Arm hoch.
Also er denkt vor allem, Arm hoch, und dann geht der Arm hoch.
Wie unendlich nervig muss das sein, jedes Mal, Arm zum Glas, jetzt bitte, Arm schliessen, Hand hoch.
Das ist auch nicht wert.
Man muss sagen, die letzte große Meldung von Stephen Hawking war, Menschen nehmen euch in acht, Artificial Intelligence will uns alle umbringen. Ciao, das war's von mir, das war mein Leben auf der Erde. Wo man sich auch fragt, das ist nicht so, er war ein fröhlicher Mensch, aber dass er damit, dass er sein, wie nennt man das, Closer, sein Closer war. Schade, ein bisschen, ja. Stimmt schon ach, oh Gott, tolle Sachen. Aber da frage ich mich auch so, wenn der wirklich mit seinem Gehirn steuern kann, und es ist möglich, Leute, glaubt mir einfach, ey Leute, die Technik, die Technik geht mit der Geschwindigkeit voran, dass man wirklich so denkt, man kann auch so Pac-Man oder spielen, kann man mit Gedanken spielen, so ist einfach so, muss ich jetzt auch nicht erklären. Ja, akzeptieren wir. Die quantenphysikalischen Hintergründe muss ich euch jetzt nicht lange ausbreiten. Das würde nur eine Zeit dauern. Aber da denke ich mir, wenn der sagt, vorne bitte, weil das ist ja höflich zu seinem eigenen Auto. Ich sage auch immer, Alexa, kannst du bitte das Licht im Schlafzimmer ausmachen? Bitte, bitte, bitte. Und dann fährt er nach vorne. Was würde passieren, wenn ihn jemand nach vorne schieben würde? Geht es dann wieder zurück? Denkt er dann automatisch, vorne, vorne, vorne, obwohl das nicht denkt, also ist es wie dann auch rückwärts oder was. Es kommt so ein großer Boxhandschuh hinten aus dem Holzschuh. Ey, der hatte bestimmt Raketen da drin oder so Öl, das man hinten rausspritzt. So ist er auch gestorben, weil er seinen Raketenantrieb getestet hat. In der James-Bond-esken Verfolgungslager. Apropos Rakete, sorry, Topical Island, schmeiß noch mal die Musik an. Topical Island, Topical Island. Wir haben vergessen, über Elon Musk zu sprechen, wie er einen Tesla in den fucking Weltraum geschossen hat. Ich hab's noch nicht verstanden, er hat ein Auto ins Weltraum gefahren. Richtig, aus Scheiss. Und das Ding ist ja, ich finde, er hat so ein bisschen Gag liegen lassen, so ein Prank irgendwie. Zumindest hat man ihn nicht gehört, er hatte so einen Stress mit einem Kollegen, er hat Scheisse gebaut und er will ein bisschen anspornen den Kollegen und er hat nicht geliefert und irgendwann geht der Kollege so raus und will zu seinem Auto gehen auf dem Parkplatz und er guckt so in den Himmel und denkt sich, what? Elon, das wäre ein geiler Prank gewesen, einfach wenn man es kann, das Autos jetzt im Weltall. Das gesamte Forscherteam sitzt da und alles so, ja geil, Tesla wählt all die, wir haben es geschafft.
Wessen Tesla war das? War das mein Tesla? Shit, was? Und dann kommt der Test mit der Fernbedienung. Ja, genau. Und dann in der Nacht, in die Live-Game, ja. Und dann dieser Wackeldackel, da immer so, fick dich. Das ist der Moment, wenn man merkt, man ist der Unbeliebteste im Büro. Vor allem, wenn jetzt Aliens vorbeikommen. Angenommen, jetzt kommen Aliens vorbei und dann sehen die unseren Planeten und dann sehen die auch Satelliten und dann schwebt da so ein Auto rum. Was denken die, ist hier passiert? Ja, aber wer sagt denn, dass, sag ich mal, zum Beispiel der Mond nicht irgendwie ein Fahrzeug aus einer alten vergangenen Zivilisation ist, die das ähnlich gemacht haben. Vielleicht ist das ja auch ein Raumschiff. Ohne Scheiss, es kommen ein paar Star Wars Filme jetzt, für Star Wars 27 oder so, fände ich geil, wenn die den Mond wie den Todesstern anmalen. Alter, wäre das geil. Das ist ein Marketing-Stand, das ist geil. Mit so Lasern kann man ihn theoretisch auch irgendwie anmalen. Kann man das hinkriegen. Ist so ein Beamer einfach, einfach so ein Beamer? So einen starken Beamer. Einfach einen starken Beamer. Guck mal, das Logo hinten ist auch immer ein Beamer drauf und es sieht ganz gut aus. Und das sind jetzt, was sagen wir mal, 20 Meter, ich hab keine Ahnung, wirklich, man weiss es nicht, wir sind echt, wie haben wir überlebt? Es ist nicht so schlecht, Wie tief ist diese Bühne? Pi mal Daumen. Zwanzig Meter? Ich hab wirklich... Leute lachen, also wahrscheinlich nicht. Das ist mein einziger Anhaltspunkt. Man sagt was, Leute lachen, okay, falsche Richtung. Das ist wie so heiß, heiß, kalt, kalt, kalt. Zwölf Meter. Aber das ist eine gute Idee, ey. Mondprojektoren oder vom Mond was projizieren auf die Erde? Das passiert die ganze Zeit. Und dann bricht wirklich die Aufgabe des Mondes. Sonne. Sonne. Einfach ein riesiges... Hat nicht mal Sonne gerufen? Sonne. Sonne oder einfach so ein riesiges Dia vor die Sonne! Sonne! Einfach ein riesiges... Hat er nicht mal Sonne gerufen? Sonne! Sonne! Oder einfach so ein riesiges Dia vor die Sonne schieben. Dann hat er irgendwie so... Die ganze Welt sind deine dummen Urlaubsfotos einfach so. Und er so, nee, komm, die nächsten hundert Jahre jetzt... Nicht heute. Was ist mit Bademoden eigentlich? Weil früher hat man gesagt... Erkennt mir kurz den Übergang.
Ja, weil ich mir dachte gerade so, okay, da sind dann so Strandfotos auf die Erde projiziert und man denkt sich, oh Gott, Papa, ey, warum so enge Badehosen?
Aber früher war das halt cool.
Aber tut sich da noch was auf dem Bademodenmarkt?
Oder bin ich mit meiner knöchellangen Badehose immer noch der coolste?
Nee, man muss wirklich sagen, da gab es einen Stichtag. Ich glaube, da gab es einen Stichtag, wo man gesagt hat, so, und jetzt tragen wir nur noch lange Badehosen. Weil plötzlich waren die anderen, man wurde beäugt, wenn man diese Slip-artigen Badehosen noch anhatte. Wie nennt man das? Speedo. Ja, Speedo. Die sind nicht mehr cool. Man muss halt diese lange tragen. Und mittlerweile, mittlerweile, ich lebe tragen. Und mittlerweile, ich lebe, ich lebe,
wird es schwarz vor Augen langsam, und mittlerweile werden die immer wieder kürzer. Die sind immer noch in diesem stoffartigen Gdöns, aber ein bisschen kürzer. Für mich war immer das absolute Kriterium einer Badehose, du brauchst eine Tasche. Eine Tasche? Du brauchst eine Tasche! Damit man das Handy mitnehmen kann und es kaputt geht. Du brauchst eine Tasche. Ist ja klar, da hast du dann so einen Lutscher drin. Aber das muss ich dir auch noch erzählen. Ich war letztens zum Thema Sachen in Taschen. Ist ein kleiner Umweg, aber wir kommen hin. Wir haben Zeit. Wir kommen da hin. Johanna hat heute nichts mehr vor. Und deswegen, ich war im Zug und es gibt ja wirklich, ich wurde, es gab mal die Idee einer Prankshow, sag ich mal. Von uns? auch von uns. Nicht ursprünglich von uns, aber... Wir wollten mal eine Prankshow machen, die heißt, wie lange würde es dauern? Richtig. Kann man mal sagen, einfach. Stimmt. Wo wir Dinge machen und man guckt, wie lange würde es dauern. Zum Beispiel, da müssen wir Beyonce fragen, ob sie Bock hat, aber wie lange würde es dauern, wie lange müsste Beyonce spielen an einem Abend, bis Fans von ihr sagen das ist jetzt schon sehr lang ja leider muss ich spielen wir dachten auch weil du das mal erkannt irgendwo wie lange also wie lange müsstest du dann mit dem den tag verbringen bis er sagt ja es gibt ja es ist ja ja ohne hier kann ich es gibt ja es gibt ja so wie das von zum beispiel von dagi b die irgendwie da können die fans von dagi b Ich hasse das ja, wenn die Leute dann immer irgendwie... Oh, hier mein Merch, mein Merch, mein Merch... Und dann verkaufen die ganze Merch-Zeug die ganze Zeit. Merch! Dann kaufen die Merch bei Dagi Bee so diese Box und bei manchen Fans bringt Dagi Bee die Box persönlich vorbei und dann rasten die natürlich aus. Und ah, krass, und die Mutter backt einen Kuchen und so. Und dann denke ich mir auch so, wie lange müsste Dagi Bee jetzt bleiben bei diesem zwölfjährigen Fan, bis der Fan sagt so, du, äh, Takmara. Vor allem dann beginnen diese Rausch-Malsgeräusche, die das sooo. Und man fängt es dann mit dem Schlüssel zu klappern oder so. In der Schule war es das Etui, was man immer zugemacht hat. Auch dieses schlechte Zeichen ist folgendes, du, dieses Reiben, das Reiben des Knies, du, jetzt ist es so, ich habe um zwölf schwimmen und niemand ist im Haus und du hast keinen Schlüssel jetzt. Ich denke mir auch, aber leider hat sowohl Beyonce als auch Dagibe nicht auf mail at gutearbeit.de geantwortet, von daher konnte das nie umgesetzt werden. At backwerf at hotmail.de nicht geantwortet. Ja, leider nicht. Aber da gibt es viele Ideen. Auch ich hatte mir so einen Soft-Eismann, man kann ja kleiner anfangen. Das war dann die Idee. Es kam erst Dagi Bee, Beyonce dann Soft-Eismann. Auf der hat nicht geantwortet. Man freut sich ja, wenn man sehr viel bekommt, aber wie viel muss der reinmachen, bis man sagt, okay, danke, danke, das reicht. Oder wie viele Trailer im Kino zeigen, bis jemand einfach sagt, Leute, sind es hier drei Stunden? Ich glaube, es würde wirklich lange dauern, bis der Erste zu dem Popcornmann geht und sagt, Leute, was ist hier los? Aber es war bei Star Wars wieder, sorry Leute aber bleibt es dabei, kann auch hier ein anderer Film sein, aber mit einer Mitternachtspremiere und dann fing der Film an und er war zwar 3D, aber die 3D-Technik kann nicht funktioniert, deswegen war alles so zweimal zu sehen und ich dachte mir, wie lange dauert es, da habe ich diese Prank-Choy im Kopf gehabt, wie lange würde es dauern, bis jemand reagiert, keine Sekunde und das ganze Kino und halt das war der hardcore fans und so und dann haben die auch schon die lichtschwert hochgehoben und angemacht und ich dachte mir bitte ich will nicht der sein der sagt leute ich der aufstehen sagt können wir das noch mal irgendwie können wir nicht sondern aber ich dachte ich muss es ich muss das nicht machen weil das ganze kino unisono aufgesprungen ist
gesagt nein das darf es nicht wahr sein
ich glaube das ist auch die red bull drin hatten weil es mal weil die mitternachtsvorstellung lange dauert das ist auch die einzige aufgabe eines projektionisten ist der schmeißt das ding an und horchtern aufschreien einfach nach nach groben wilden Rufen. Und wenn er so winkt vor dem Fenster winken. Ich hatte heute zwei Winker. Also abendessen Gespräche. Das ist auch so, ich versuche ja immer, obwohl ich mit Tickets fahre, oft im Zug, sorry, es ist ein Podcast, wir müssen über Zuge reden, sorry, es ist einfach im Zug hergefallen, im Zug, ist es dann oft so, dass ich dann Kopfhörer habe und dann oft nicht kontrolliert werden will. Man wird ja auch oft nicht kontrolliert, obwohl man noch nicht kontrolliert wurde. Und dann gibt es auch oft diesen Handwischer so vor den Augen, so das dann auch mal so... Oh, ich wurde nur ganz sachte aufgestürmelt, wachgestreichelt so. Aber wirklich so, und ich mir dachte, wie lange berühst du mich jetzt schon? Man wacht dann auf und es war so eine Spur zu fürsorglich. Ja, ja, nach meiner Erektion zu urteilen schon eine Weile. Das hat einfach zu lange gedauert. Wow. Worauf ich aber ursprünglich raus wollte, ist die Prankshow war irgendwie so, wie lange hält man es aus neben einer unbekannten Person im Zug oder so was. So, du sitzt im Zug und was müsst ihr machen? Und ich denke mir, seitdem man diese Idee formuliert hat, denke ich mir, ich bin in dieser Prankshow, Weil letztens war ich wirklich, saß ich im Zug und der Mann neben mir packte eine Plastiktüte aus, randvoll, also eine Plastiktüte, randvoll mit Leberwurst. Ganz kurz, es war die Orte... War die Orte... Es hat al verpackt. Nein, es war nicht die Verpackung der Leberwurst. Ich wiederhole nochmal. Es war eine Plastiktüte gefüllt mit Leberwurst. Wir reden nicht von einer Tupperdose, die geöffnet wird und darin ist eine Plastiktüte. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Wir reden von einer Plastiktüte voller Leberwurst. Wenn ihr euch manchmal fragt, denken die sich das eigentlich immer alles aus, muss ich immer sagen, nein. Aber, das ist der eine Fall, wo ich sagen würde, das ist wirklich so Leberwurst und ich dachte mir so, okay, was passiert jetzt, was ist jetzt, ich dachte erst, okay, jetzt kommt ein Brot, so, ich dachte, jetzt kommt halt ein Brot und mein gut, meine Gäste kommt eine Plastiktüte voller Brote, eine Plastiktüte voller Messer und los geht's ich bin vorbereitet für den ganzen zu ja ja vor stuttgart keine reagiert okay alles klar ich habe auch noch abflüge aber es war wirklich dachte mir so ja gut kennt man ja man geht stürmt morgens aus dem haus und jetzt halt nicht die Zeit, noch sein Leberwurstbrot zu schmieren.
Dann nimmt man halt Leberwurst und Brot separat mit und schmiert sich das halt im Zug. Stattdessen kam der zweite Griff zu einem kleinen Löffel. Ah, und der Löffel... Und das ist wirklich, ich denke mir das nicht aus. Und ich dachte mir da schon, kleiner Löffel?
Kleiner Löffel... Und das ist wirklich, ich denk mir das nicht aus. Und ich dachte mir da schon, kleiner Löffel? Kleiner Löffel? Wenn, angenommen, ich hätte Lust, Leberwurst zu löffeln. Der kleine Löffel ist nicht meine erste Wahl. Nennt mich exzentrisch, aber wirklich. Aber clever. Ich nenne wirklich ernsthaft. Geht tief in euch, geht tief in euch und überlegt euch zum Beispiel mal Erdnussbutter oder auch einfach mal Nutella. Es ist nicht der kleine Löffel. Es war der kleine Löffel und er wirklich genüsslich, so ein Sipverschluss bei der Plastitüte, war nicht die erste Füllung, nehme ich an. Holy shit. Sip auf undelt. Und löffelt direkt rein. Das war und auch teilweise, ich nenne ihn den Eiscreme-Löffler, nach unten gewölbt und gekratzt. Um eine Kugel zu bekommen. Um diese schöne Hägen-Das-Welle zu bekommen. Ich lehne malurst. Es war genau das, schön reingelöffelt. Und an dem Moment dachte ich mir so, okay, jetzt bringt es aber auch zu Ende, Kollege. Und es war wirklich, es ist jetzt Quatsch, was ich sage, weil ihr habt gesehen, dass ich 20 Meter nicht schätzen kann. Ich würde schätzen, es waren gute 400 Gramm. Es war wirklich so gute, es war wirklich ordentlich Leberwurst. Und es war halt einfach seine Unterhaltung für die Zugfahrt. Das war keine Mahlzeit, das war einfach, er hat das gegessen. Ich denke mir oft, wenn Leute so in den Zug steigen und man fährt so vier Stunden lang Köln, Berlin. Leute, die die Unterhaltung sich mitbringen, ist perfekt. Ja, und Leute, die keine Unterhaltung mitbringen, sind die dümmsten Menschen der Welt. Sorry an der Stelle. Sie schauen dich an. Sie sind meistens dann so neben dir. Obwohl auch Gespräche. Dere Unterhaltung ist, glaube ich, Gespräche anfangen mit Leuten. Wo fahren Sie hin? Nee, auf keinen Fall. Bei mir ist es wirklich so, ich steige wie in so ein Mech-Suit ein. So, ich steige wirklich in den Sitz, Klappe runter, Tisch runter, Laptop drauf, Festplatte, eingesteckt, reingesteckt, Marte an, Kopfhörer auf, zack, Curb Enthusiasm an und schön ballern vier Stunden lang.
Ich bin eingeklingt, ich bin drin, ich komme nicht mehr raus.
Und wenn der Laptop leer ist, auch weiter drauf gucken einfach, um so ein Anschein zu erwecken, als ob er uns Zeit hat und angesprochen werden will. Aber immer wieder sitze ich neben Leuten, die sitzen da und dann ziehen sie Rehker aus und Rucksack auf und dann dieses...
Ja. Und dann vor allem, sag mal, was hast du erwartet, dass jetzt passiert? Und dann nicht mal der Fensterplatz. Wirklich. Einfach, wo ich mir denke, du Depp einfach so. Und dann kommt immer das aller, wo man merkt, okay, die Reise wird nichts mehr, der Griff zum Bahnmagazin. Und man weiß, na na na na. Und dann das Weglegen mit kenne ich schon. Der macht sich mehr lange einfach so. macht sich, Colin Fernandes, es gibt nichts anderes einfach so. Es sind vor allem Leute, die auch nicht ans Fenster gehen, wo man denkt, okay, ihr habt wirklich so eine Art Fernseher, wo ihr hinsetzen könnt und die Welt vorbeiziehen seht. Nein, nicht mal das, das ist meist im Gang. Gar nichts. Das ist traurig. Und ich dachte neulich, wie geil wäre es, wenn man an der Autobahn fährt und wenn man genau sich an die Geschwindigkeit hält, bildet sich links so eine Art Kino. Nämlich da sind sehr viele Schilder in dem richtigen Abstand, dass wenn man genau 120 fährt, man einen Film sehen kann, Garfield zum Beispiel. Ach, du meinst 24 Bilder pro Sekunde oder was? Ja, genau. Wenn man genau 120 fährt, kann man diesen Film verstehen. Sonst sieht man einfach sehr viele Schilder mit Bildern. Aber es muss doch gehen, oder nicht? Das geht, geht das? Weiß ich nicht. Waren das die ersten Kinos, einfach eine lange Reihe Menschen, die Bilder und dann ist man einfach vorbeigerannt einfach. Wir brauchen schnelle Leute. Ja, es müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren, Daumen-Kinoprinzip. Chinesische U-Bahn. Chinesische U-Bahn. Danke, ist das dein Podcast oder was machst du? Wahnsinn. Ist das, funktioniert das so? Ach, in China kann man Kinofilme sehen. Okay, gut. Das ist eine mega geile. Chinesen sind es immer zu weit. Das ist so, Stefan Tietze plus zwei Jahre ist China. Einfach so, alles, was du jetzt denkst, gibt es in China schon. Cool, ich finde es nicht so schlecht. Also ich finde es eine gute Idee. Sollte man vielleicht machen, vielleicht ist man auch sofort abgelenkt und baut Tracey Unfälle. Ich glaube, das ist das Hauptproblem, dass man Autofahrern nicht notwendigerweise ablenken will. Ja, ja. Ich glaube, aber... Ich bin häufig abgelenkt von den Schildern, die mir sagen, dass ich mich nicht ablenken lassen soll. Zwei Menschen, einer fährt, zwei Menschen ste... Was stand da gerade? Ja, ablenken lassen, von wann was? Was stand da gerade? Nicht schlecht. Auf jeden Fall aß er seine Leberwurst, Stück für Stück. Und es war wirklich keine Mahlzeit. Man kennt das ja, man holt sich eine Apfeltasche und denkt sich, okay, fuck, der ganze Zuckerkuss klebt an der Tüte, es ist keine Apfeltasche mehr für mich. Aber er hat das wirklich die gesamte Zeit weggesnackt und aber am Ende kam für mich noch das absolute Highlight und zwar er löffelte es aus und dann dachte ich mir, dann ist er immer so das Ding, was macht er jetzt mit dem Löffel? Der Löffel ist ja jetzt nicht mehr sauber, so einen sauberen Löffel, in den Plastikbeutel, sauberen Löffel, hat sich gerade übergeben da jemand da? Und bei einem sauberen Löffel kannst du ja einen Rucksack tun. Aber das ist ja noch die Sache, der Abgeleckte, was macht er damit? Er ist also fertig und wirklich kratzt, wirklich die letzten zwei Gramm, wirklich, also wie aus einem Nutella-Glas, die letzten bisschen Leerwurst, schlägt es ab, schlägt es nochmal ab und steckt den Löffel in seinen Geldbeutel. What the fuck? Was hat er vor? Ich dachte mir einfach, touche. Wahnsinn. Ein Löffel im Geldbeutel ist die beste Idee, die ich seit der chinesischen U-Bahn gehört habe. Du hast eigentlich immer einen Löffel dabei, du hast immer wirklich einen Geldbeutel. Stell dir mal raus, du musst irgendwie jemandem Geld leihen und du holst einen Geldbeutel raus, er schaut einfach so einen Löffel daraus. Zwanzig, dreißig, ganz, ganz, ganz kurz. Stimmt so und legt den Löffel noch in. Wahnsinn. Das alte Piratendilemma, so du verlierst deine Hand und du gehst dann so zum Amputeur-Typ und der hat dann so eine große Man, der hat dann so eine große Varietät, so Korkenzieher, Löffel, Haken, was wollen Sie? Und der hätte definitiv gesagt, ich nehme einen Löffel. Ich nehme aber den kleinen Löffel. Ich nehme den kleinen Löffel. Und dann Nachtisch, schön Erdbeereis. Aber es ist wirklich, also irgendwo läuft in Deutschland ein Mann herum, der hat einen Löffel. Allein dieser Gedanke, zu wissen, wenn ihr heute Nacht im Bett liegt und euch Ritter aus der Lands Landschaft anschaut und einfach nicht einschlafen könnt und ihr denkt euch, irgendwo ist jetzt dieser Mann da draußen und es sieht die Welt, es gibt ja dieses Sprichwort, wenn du ein Hammer bist, siehst du in der Welt lauter Nägel, Platon, glaube ich, oder irgendwie sowas. Wenn man wie ein Hammer denkt, wird alles zum Nagel. Ihr versteht, was ich meine. Ja, man versteht, was ich meine. Selektive Wahrnehmung.
Wie sieht die Welt für jemanden aus, der einen Löffel im Geldbeutel hat, der einfach allzeit bereit ist, so ich könnte alles löffeln, ich könnte wirklich alles löffeln, egal was es ist. Fantastisch. Und dann kommt da irgendwie so im Supermarkt so Probesachen und er so, zack. Ich bin vorbereitet. Das finde ich, das ist wirklich mein Held. Aber hat er den Löffel in einem Löffelfach? Also wie man sich das vorstellt. Oder gab es da noch andere Besteckartikel? Nee, er hat nur einen Löffel und zwar ins Scharnier. Ins Geldfach Scharnier. Quer oder hochkant? So, dass die, naja, dass der Löffel aufeinander. Das, was ein Löffel zum Löffel macht, noch oben drauf rausschaut. Scoop, würde man glaube ich sagen. Gott sei Dank passieren dir so viele lustige Dinge im Zug, ey. Ja, es ist wirklich, aber es ist unfassbar. Ich wollte ja immer so, man wollte ja, ich meine, da haben wir schon oft zu probieren, so einen UCP haben. UCP haben, ne, USP. USP. UPS. Immer immer erstmal Abkürzungen sagen und dann erklären. Jeder sollte was haben, jeder sollte seinen eigenen Löffel haben. Und ich wollte immer einen Chubber-Chubbs-Lutscher dabei haben. Ja, okay. Also wirklich immer so der, der immer einen Chubber-Chubbs-Lutscher dabei hat. Aber habe ich nie durchgezogen, weil ich immer so, weil ich das Haus verlassen habe,, ja, ich habe noch einen Chubber-Chub-Lutscher. Jetzt ein Lutscher. Wahnsinn. Ich würde gerne diesen Menschen begegnen, nochmal. Ich würde ihn auch gerne einfach im Tag noch mal bezeichnen. Und hier ist Harald, meine Damen und Herren! Oh, no way! Tut mir leid. Nein, wir sind nicht gut vorbereitet. Das wär's. Das wär's gewesen. Fantastisch. Mega, mega Story. Was kann man direkt so straight weglöffeln? Gibt's Obst, das man direkt löffeln kann? Kiwi! Kiwi! Ein Wort, auf ein Wort fokussiert, das werde ich jetzt sagen. Seit Anfang wartet sie, come on, come on, come on, den hab ich, den hab ich, den hab ich, den hab ich, ist ja oft so. Im Unterricht hat man auch oft eine Antwort im Kopf. Ja, genau.
Wenn die Frage gestellt wird.
Das wäre so bei einer Quizshow mein Problem.
Ich habe die Antwort schon im Kopf.
Nur die richtige Frage muss kommen.
Und ich will einfach sofort der Erste sein.
Aber das ist auch oft so die Welt.
Also so Kiwi, wie essen Tiere Kiwis? Die sind einfach alles scheißegal.
Die essen in dem Pferd.
Die Tiere sind oft alles scheißegal.
Aber einfach so mit so einem Löffel.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, wo ich mir auch dachte, konstruktives Feedback an die Evolution. Manche Sachen, also zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, ob du manchmal Erdnüsse isst, aber so mit in Schale drin. Dann haben die ja die Schale und um die Erdnuss selber ist da nochmal so eine Haut drin. Meine persönliche Meinung, die innere Haut bräuchte ich nicht, kann für mich weg, brauche ich nicht. Du hast schon eine äussere Haut. So, jetzt lebst du aber in einer Welt, wo es diese Haut gibt. Und vielleicht magst du die Erdnuss nur so gerne, weil diese Haut existiert. Ach du meinst, weil dieses Gefühl zu sein muss. Wie diese quadratischen Fruchtgummi-Dinger, die es nur kostenlos gibt. Also die man immer nur bei Ärzten oder so kostenlos reingeht. Oder am Ende vom Restaurants. Einfach immer so denkst du, was stellen wir in unsere Praxis an Süßigkeiten, die widerlichsten Süßigkeiten. Diese Viereckigen, die sich nicht mehr gefärbt haben, die direkt immer weiß sind, auch wenn es Kirsch ist. Wahrscheinlich lagen da erst Snickers und die waren dann sofort weg und dann dachte mir sich, na okay, wir gehen eine Stufe mal runter, wir gehen mal auf Twix-Niveau, ohne jetzt hier einen Bürgerkrieg auf anfangen zu beheulen, ist ein anderes Thema. Und irgendwann waren die alle weg und dann dachte sie, alles was übrig bleibt. Man kennt diese Erdnüsse, die cheaten? Pistazien, ja, ich hasse sie. Es gibt Erdnüsse, die haben zwei so Wobbel, zwei so Kammern, man macht sie auf, nur eine Erdnuss drin. Man nimmt sich, what, ist das denn fucking ernst? Selbst so eine gute Erdnuss kann man noch pranken. Ja, wenn ich mir aufmache, sehe eine Film und denkt mir, viel Glück da draußen. Du schaffst es, du findest deinen Weg. Du hast es geschafft auszubrechen, wo immer du auch sein magst, du schaffst es an deinem Ziel. Das könnte ein Pixar-Film sein. Die eine Erdnuss, die verkauft wird und merkt, Paul, Paul, wo ist Paul und dann so Finding Paul. Naja, gut, in 20 Jahren. Es gibt schon sowas ähnliches, aber in diesem, ganz kurz, der Kosmos Cars, können wir noch mal einen Film machen, der in dem Kosmos von Cars spielt, aber nicht Cars ist, was lebt da noch eigentlich, leben da nur Autos? Vor allem die Autos gucken ja auch zu, das sind ja auch die Zuschauer. Was machen Toaster in der Welt, haben die ein eigenes Leben? Es ist auch so ein bisschen die Pokémon-Frage, gibt es da auch normale Menschen, die einsteigen und dann einfach in so ein entsprechendes Auto steigen? Keine Menschen. Gab es da Tiere? Ich habe Carsten nie gesehen. Keine Ahnung. Ich stehe oft vor der Wahl, schaue mir einen neuen Film an, und dann schaue ich mir Ritter aus Leidenschaft an. Weil es ist einfach ein cooler Film, es ist einfach Spaß. Wir müssen langsam zum Ende kommen, Florentin. Es war ein fantastischer Abend mit euch. Also wir sind froh, dass wir das gemacht haben. Wir waren mega aufgeregt. Es ist die erste Show. Ihr wart heute live bei der allerersten Live-Show von zwei. Von zwei. Ihr seid die erste Hälfte. Holy shit. Wow. Das nimmt euch keiner mehr weg.
Das stimmt.
Was euch auch keiner mehr wegnimmt, ist ein schickes T-Shirt. Könnt ihr im Anschluss noch am Merchstand holen.
Falls es noch wer hier gibt, ich weiß nicht. Aber das war die erste Live-Show. Wir gucken mal, wie es weitergeht. Aber vielen Dank, dass ihr mit uns hier wart und den allerersten Testflug zu zeigen. Es war ein Testflug und ich habe so ein Galaxien. Bestimmt habt ihr vorher vielleicht auch gedacht, ja, vielleicht stellen sie einfach nur so einen Ghetto-Blaster auf die Bühne und spielen halt eine gute Folge Podcast-Rof ab. Ne, wir haben es wirklich durchgezogen. Ich bin froh, dass wir es gemacht haben. Ja, vielen Dank an euch, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Ich hoffe, ihr habt ein bisschen Spaß. Du hattest einen schönen Geburtstag. Ich hoffe, es war. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart, ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen, ich hoffe, Joana, du hattest einen schönen Geburtstag, ich hoffe es war.
Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön, vielen Dank fürs Kommen und natürlich zum Ende der Folge.
Wir heben ab.
Macht's gut, tschau, tschau, tschau.